For me, entrepreneurship has always been
the way.
>> Investing is important because it's the
only way you are going to be able to get
rich and wealthy for your family. We can
>> we can
>> close the wealth gap.
>> Close the gap
>> by working together.
>> Market Monday is the biggest investment
show ever.
>> My life is literally changed since
watching EL. [music]
>> When you can make people money, you can
add value. They're going to be forever
indebted to you. And
>> I promise you this year I'm going to
make all even more money.
Disclaimer: Do your own research. Our
content is intended to be used and must
be used forformational purposes only.
It's very important to do your own
analysis before making any investment
based on your own personal
circumstances. You should take
independent financial advice from a
professional in connection with or
independently research and verify any
information that you find on our show
and wish to rely upon whether for the
purpose of making an investment decision
or otherwise. Let's build our knowledge,
our community, and our brokerage
accounts. Love is love.
>> Love is love.
>> What's the deal?
>> Check five. How y'all feeling?
>> In the flesh. What's the We We back. We
blessed.
>> Still alive.
>> We here.
>> We here. Love is love. You know, we
always going to spread that.
>> Happy to be here.
>> What's the deal, my brother? How you
feeling,
>> man? Bless Holly favorite. Shout out to
uh y'all. Shout out to the all black
attire. Shout out to black effect. All
things black. Love y'all.
>> I'm everybody black. [laughter]
>> How you feeling, man?
>> I feel blessed.
>> I feel blessed. God is the greatest. You
know that. At all times. At all times.
You know that.
>> That's a fact.
>> It's a it's it's a blessing to still be
here and still kicking and still be able
to wake up and do and do my favorite
show, Marketing Mondays.
>> Yeah. We here, man. We here. It's a
blessed day. It is uh the 17th of
August. Happy birthday, Lil London. It's
her third birthday. We just gonna start
with the love.
>> Shout out to AB. Shout out to Sh is our
baby girls. And I say a cuz that's
family. That's like real family.
>> Her third birthday today. So,
congratulations to her. Shout out to uh
Joe. Fact. Joe had his birthday
yesterday.
>> Oh, okay.
>> Yeah. Shout out to Joey.
>> Yeah, man. It's Leo season, man. Shout
out to everybody. Mr. Two weeks out. My
boy Jay.
>> Shout out to my boy. Yeah, it was his
birthday as well, man. We saw him.
That's that's an honorable dude, man.
Shout out to him.
>> That's a fact. Shout out to the bro,
man. So, yeah, you know, um we get into
it. We got a a jams packed show today.
>> Yeah.
>> We might talk about a few topics that is
trending out there. You know that. Um
but first and foremost, I would like to
say, now we going to get into it.
Blackout on Wednesday.
>> Yeah.
>> Your favorite show is back. 9:00 Eastern
Standard Time. We going to be going
live. We got two guests. We got my
brother 19 keys and we got Van Lean.
>> Hey, let's go.
>> Hey,
>> shout out to Van Le. You know,
>> good combo today.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
>> Yeah, man. Anybody catch last week's
Blackout?
>> I think a few people [laughter]
>> Blackout.
>> Yeah, man. Legendary. Thank you. Thank
you for being here [laughter]
respectfully. Thank you.
>> Oh, man. We We here.
>> Love. Um, Thursday at 12:00 Eastern
Standard Time.
>> Yeah.
>> Earn your leisure. We got the great
legend Serena Williams. Um the
Investfest conversation. We gonna put
that out and that's going to be on
YouTube. That's gonna be on all podcast
outlets.
>> And um we got we got some other things
that we gonna get to.
>> Yeah,
>> for sure. Any um any announcements, Ian?
>> Yeah, I want to say happy uh belated
birthday to my cousin Joe Mlan.
Appreciate you. Uh happy belated to
Andre Drummond. Have an amazing season.
And then Stock Club, I'm probably going
to do a pop-up session on Friday for us
to go through some questions um post
Investfest about charting, where the
market is going. Check Telegram to those
of you who joined the Red Panda family.
Thank you so much from the bottom of my
heart. Um check Telegram every single
day. Prices will be coming out in a
week. Um and then at the end of this
month, we're going to start doing Friday
sessions every single Friday. If I made
you money, please put yes in chat and
let's have an amazing show.
>> Yeah. Yeah. It's uh you know what I woke
up this morning and I felt that energy
again that you know I'm back in the I'm
back in the lab. I'm back in front of
the computer at 6:30 in the morning.
>> You know invest is such a huge task that
you kind of like lose a little bit of
the steam that you so used to and for
the first time this morning I was like
oh I'm back in
>> oh bro I'm back. I was I was up at 6:30
waiting to put up a message in ELU. I
waited till eight o'clock to put it up
just because I know like there there's
like a schedule like I know the workout
you know group is gonna put that thing
in. Shout out to my brother Malcolm. He
gonna put his breakdown and his good
message of the day. I was like let me
just wait till 8 o'clock. Shout out to
Steph. She had a joint. I'm like all
right I'm excited. Let's go. Uh so I was
looking at the market. I was looking at
the memory sector. We'll talk about it.
I was like all right. Boom. Let me tell
them what I'm seeing. That energy is
back man. So shout out to everybody in
Red Panda. Shout out to all all the the
family. Shout out to Ernest as well.
>> Yes sir. [sighs]
shop earn your leisure.com for these uh
memorable takes. Support black business
at all times. Um we gonna get to all the
topics on the side of the show.
>> You're a funny dude. Yo, you you you low
key the dry humor. Amazing. Fire Tra
>> at all at all times. Um the side the
side of the page shows the topics that
we will be covering. So um
>> okay
>> you can see that you can see the the
chronological order in which we will be
discussing topics. So stay tuned.
>> Mhm.
>> Stay tuned.
>> Even in that in a buildup, can you talk
about how important it is to have a
cliffhanger like from a media standpoint
um and how to take adversity and turn it
into triumph and monetization. Really
quick on a since we going to start on a
positive business note. [sighs]
all the entrepreneurs out there,
>> man. You got to stay positive at all
times and uh when life throws you
limits, you got to make lemonade out of
it. And um you got to make the best out
of the out of the cards that you're
dealt.
>> Um so yeah, I got to be careful with my
words right now because I'm very viral
in the moment if you haven't noticed. Um
so I don't want I don't want to get
clipped up. I don't want to get clipped
up.
>> No, I'mma stop you this episode. Go
crazy. I'm
>> Youried You tried to set me up. What's
he in for?
>> You tried to set [laughter] me up. You
tried to set me up.
>> As a man, everything on earth is your
your fault. I take all responsibility
for all things.
>> The good brother.
>> Um, okay. Let's get into it because this
is an investment show, guys. So, I know
I know I know why you're here.
>> Yeah.
>> Um, well, I know why the core audience
is here, but you know, there's a couple
people that's not the core audience
that's here. But don't worry, we going
to get to it. We never run. Um, we never
f we going to we going to stand and um
we going to talk. when we have a
conversation, but first we going to give
you some educ education that you can
actually make some money cuz uh that's
what it's really about making money at
the end of the day. So, what's the
investment fact of the week, Ian?
>> I actually have four. Um number one,
write this down. Toot, which is the bond
market, is approaching its lowest level
since 2002. And the yield has hit a
level that we have not seen in probably
10 or 15 years. I keep asking everyone
on Earth, when is the bond market going
to recover? and no one has given me a
clear answer yet. Um, number two, Nike's
hit a 12-year low. Uh, the stock has
officially erased over $200 billion in
market cap since the record high. And we
were talking before Nike. I have no
disparaging remarks uh, regarding you
today. But the thing that is concerning
is when I'm looking at the chart, there
is no
protection mechanism to stop the free
fall from happening. I mean, technically
looking at it, we could fall back to the
levels that they were at 2000, which
would be heartbreaking on on a
commercial side. So, um I think Kanye
and Troy need to go to Portland and
figure things out with them in Oregon
about how to turn the company around
ASAP. So, if y'all can make that call,
please do so. Number three, since the
start of 2025, the tech sector is up
65%. In the same time, the 4P ratio has
fallen from 29x to 22x and the national
debt is up to almost 40 trillion with a
T dollar. So if we have degradation of
the consumer sector,
the bond market, which is the um the
debt market or obligations market, that
is down that's been down for six years.
Imagine if the tech sector was down six
years. We would have absolutely
>> uh rage in the streets, right?
>> But there isn't as much talk about the
bond market in the same regard and I
think there should be. And national debt
is almost $40 trillion in addition to
we'll talk about it later. The amount of
debt and AI spending that is off the
books. I think we have some time for
concern now for sure.
>> I'm going to add to this. I'm going to
add to this and I think this is
important. There's there's two lessons
in two investing facts. Um the first one
is that corrections can be sector
specific
>> for sure. Yep.
>> Right. People need to really understand
that I think Mike I think I hear you
your computer.
>> Mike, please cut your computer off,
brother. Please.
>> The uh the idea that a sector like
memory can correct and the NASDAQ still
at the all-time highs. I know it can
feel confusing, right? The S&P alltime
high Friday, the Dow, all these things
are running. Meanwhile, last week you
you saw it was fighting back. Uh what
happened today was was a great sign.
What happened Friday in terms of closing
was a great sign for the memory sector.
But when you you think about it, it
feels like especially if you're invested
in these companies, this feels like one
of the worst feelings. Like July was a
terrible month for the memory sector,
but it it it wasn't true for the energy
sector, right? Like there's certain
spots where you have to look and say,
"Okay, well, is this an overwhelming
story or is this a sector specific
story?" And we can see now that July was
definitely a sector specific. I also
think people need to realize that a
correction doesn't mean that the bull
market is over. Like that's important,
right? A correction doesn't mean that
the bull market is over. In fact, if you
look at some of the the greatest years
in terms of returns, they've had some
really solid corrections because that
means that growth can now appear. And so
what we're seeing in August and again
this is not traditional and Ian, I'm
sure you can attest and shy could attest
to it as well. What we're seeing right
now in August is not the norm.
>> Rare.
>> It's very rare. In fact, August to early
October is usually the most volatile
time in the market.
>> July usually is the best time, one of
the best months. And now we're kind of
seeing a reversal. Midterm year. We
already spoke about that since January.
>> Yeah.
It's like we should be seeing this. We
saw a correction inside of the memory
sector. True. We've now seen it start to
rebound. Micron crossed over a thousand.
It hit some technical marks and we'll
talk about a little ear a little later.
Hit cross some barriers which was a
great sign. We saw Sandis cross. Nothing
has really changed, right? The
[clears throat] story is very much the
same. Demand is still the same. And in
fact, it actually has gotten more
advantageous to be a part of it because
we're seeing signs that, hey, Apple, you
remember that demand that they put,
we're going to start using ch Chinese
memory chips. Well, the United States
government said, "Look, I don't think
so. In fact, you better make a decision
by this week if you think you're going
to do it because we're not going to
allow it." What does that do? That helps
the memory sector, specifically American
memory, specifically Micron, right?
Because it's leader in in terms of high
bandwidth memory, which is what Apple is
using. That that tide is starting to
turn as we start hitting different EMAs,
right? We're watching those technical
levels. We're crossing a lot of them.
Western Digital is up. Seagate is up.
that memory sector, right? We had a
correction and we know what's on the
other side of that. So, just be aware
that when you see a correction doesn't
necessarily mean bull market is over and
it can be sector specific. Just know
that. And even if something has went up
a,000% or 1500% is a 22% drop at
correction. Like that's the other part
when people are show so shortsided. I'm
like some of these have went up 2,000%.
A 25% drop is not
>> I know technically on paper it is. Yeah,
>> but it should I don't think it should
have been classified as a correction. It
really just went to back to asymmetric
level where you can get in and ride back
to the upside.
>> And that's the part I want to say. I'm
glad you said it.
>> A company like Sanders has shot up
over,00%.
To see it pull back 45%.
>> Bro, a lot of us were there. Let's say
we weren't in there for the entire
1100%, but a lot of us were here since
220, 230, [clears throat]
300. We ran all the way up to 2,300.
We've been here for a lot of it. So, a
slight correction is actually should
excite you because that means we're
testing higher lows so we can get to
higher highs.
>> Yeah.
>> Also,
>> okay,
>> one last point, Rashad.
>> Holding periods are very important.
Don't take it from me. Take it from the
bus family. Final part of the stake has
been liquid liquidated out of the fund.
47year hold for the Lakers. Sometimes
the success leaves clues right in front
of you. Don't focus on the next two
years. If you're trying to build
generational wealth in our community, we
have to focus on 30 and 40 your hoes.
Back to you, Rashad. My apologies.
>> Yeah. I'm saying for the people that got
in at like a high level, that's when you
start to panic. When you get in and then
it drops 40%.
>> It's not a big deal for us if we got in,
you know, early. But if you got in and
your portfolio is down 40%. And then
you're on an option call, you're down
80%.
>> Yeah,
>> that's what
>> but but even with that, I'm gonna be
very honest. Too many of you, and this
is my thoughts and my thoughts only, Red
Panda LLC and the Rebellion, too many of
you are doing the option first and not
the equities. Even if you bought some of
the top two in the sector at a high, if
you give it a year, you're going to
break the high.
>> There are some investors, some macro
funds who only buy near highs. I'm not
suggesting it. That's not the way I like
to do price discovery. But even if you
buy a great equity, one or two in a
space only, if you buy at a high,
[clears throat] it will continue to make
new highs. So yes, you can draw down.
But I think too many people are doing
the option or the trade first and not
the actual equity.
>> I think you're right. And I think one of
the thing we have to watch when it pulls
back like that is how fast it reclaims
some of its technical levels, right?
Like if it falls below it 200, how long
before it reclaims it 200? How long
before it reclaims its 100, it's 50,
it's 72, it's how long does it take?
Does it do it within 14 days? Does it
take 30 days? Because if it starts
reclaiming them, then we know that that
was a correction and now we're still
moving in that upward trend, which is
important. I think the other piece, and
we kind of talked about, so shout out to
uh the UIL you team. They put up a clip
from a class where I was talking about,
well, when we see pullbacks like that,
this is now when we the leverage that we
can we've seen people get abused on.
Like this is when you look at it and
say, "All right, this might be
>> take advantage right for us." Right?
Number one, have the shares. Number two,
do you have a call inside of that
equity? And then number three, now if
we've drawn down, can we get that
leverage on the way back up? So I I I
put a call and shout out to everybody
that's been texting me about it. They
were in the double leverage Sanders
because yeah, Sandis is an expensive
stock at this point. It's at 1,700. I
think tomorrow it's going to open at
1,800. We watched that double leverage
pull down to $3.
>> $3. It's high. it peak was 33. And so as
Sandis pulls back, the double leverage
pulls down. And so if we already have
the shares, which we do, and we have
calls already longterm, we're out to
2028 in a few of them. We have late
December 2027 and others.
>> All right. Well, here's an opportunity
that maybe we can get some time because
I've always again, make sure you use
time as Oh my gosh. Please, I'll give
you a story about coherent in a little
bit, but use time as your asset and
there there could be some some great
returns if you you you structure this
and plan this out correctly.
>> Yes, sir. 5,600 people want to check in.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> Hit the like button and share. We going
we going to get into the public address
in a minute, but we just got to, you
know, we got to give some information
first. So, if you in here for that,
>> then you'll learn for free for for the
first half an hour.
>> Yeah. You know, you know what? We forgot
to shout out.
>> Who's that?
>> Our brothers at the marathon team. Shout
out to Nick.
>> Yeah, I seen they was in New York. We
were actually out of town when they came
to do all the tapings here in New York.
Shout out to Sam BH the whole team. Yo,
Prolific is an amazing project.
>> KBY Supreme.
>> It has been an amazing roll out. I'm
happy to see them in a good place. I saw
they had like a whole family gathering.
They had Samantha there. Shout out to
Adam. Lauren was there. It was a
beautiful thing to see. Shout. It was
N's birthday on Saturday. Rest in peace
to the great one. Rest in peace. Shout
out to the whole Marathon team for
continuing that legacy and the project's
incredible. So, shout out to them.
>> Rest in peace to my brother Black Sam.
>> Yeah. Oh,
>> I mean rest in peace to Nip.
>> Shout out Shout out to my brother. Shout
out to my brother Black Sam.
>> Absolutely.
>> Shout out to my brother KB Supreme.
>> Shout out to my brother BH.
>> Shout out to my brother Pac-Man.
>> Shout out to my brother Adam. Shout out
to my brother, man, who I'm I don't want
to forget nobody on the team,
>> but um they showed us so much love
>> every time we go to LA. And you know,
it's crazy because when Sam do so many
interviews now,
>> but when he did the interview with us,
>> that was unheard of. Like he didn't talk
at all. So nobody thought that he could
even get we could even get that
interview. And I think that really, you
know, opened a lot of the like it gave
him probably even more, you know,
confidence and just made him more
comfortable because even in that
interview, he didn't want to sit down.
If you watch the interview, he's
standing up the whole interview. He
didn't want it, he didn't want it to
even feel like an interview. So that's
back that was back when he was not
talking publicly at all.
>> So it's it's just dope to see his
growth. It's dope to see him carrying on
his brother's legacy, him standing in
for his brother. That's That's
>> pause.
>> That's a pause.
>> Where?
>> To see his growth.
>> Oh, okay. Okay. Come on. All right.
Yeah. Damn. Now you got
>> I'mma be mature.
>> Stone. Shout out to Stone. Shout out to
J Stone.
>> Shout out to Jstone.
>> J Stone for sure.
>> That was crazy. [laughter]
>> Just add a little humor, my brother. You
know, I got multiple tools in the back.
I I watched I watched it in the same way
I think you watched it was like I'm just
proud to see him out there as the front
of the of this this mission and speaking
and running marathons and having a
marathon burger and welcoming everybody
into the space. It's been a long journey
for him to get to this point but to see
him here that's my Pisces brother man so
we got to support them. shout out to
them
>> and to constantly operate with integrity
and in interviews even um I love that he
finally broke down like the offers they
turn down for the documentary and like
just a classic example of operating with
integrity and showing that you can you
can still win big by operating that way
>> and JP shout out to JP also
>> oh yes JP running the marathons too
>> um futures trading tip of the week
>> yeah before we do that I want to give
some long-term value real quick um for
those who asking what ETFs to invest in
VTF EI, RSP, SPMO,
SHD, TE are all good ones. Of course, uh
DRAM, it's great, etc. But futures, uh
tip of the week, if you're taking 12
trades on a year, realize I want to give
you some numbers. Um if you get to your
13th trade, the brokerage has a 45.6
chance or the market has a chance of
beating you. So, you have a 32.1%
chance to win, 22.2% 2% chance to break
even and a casino wins about 58% 58% of
the time according to those numbers. A
lot of you don't want to hear limit your
trades, but once you go over your
allocated number of trades for the year,
realize that the house the market legal
pole figured this out the hard way
dealing with Ken,
>> there's a 58% chance that you're going
to end up losing. So for all of my
traders and investors, your homework
assignment for tonight based on the
number of trades, calculate what happens
if you take seven more trades or five
more trades on the year and see how much
damage it has on your account. So for
everyone in sniper and red hand, I
always said if you're a beginner, do 12
trades a year. Um you have a 22.2%
chance of breaking even if you get to
13. um and a 58.7%
chance of losing if you get to 16
trades. That's just four more, let alone
if you're on 30 trades for the year. Put
in chat, less is more. Um and I know
sometimes when I tell you to only take
12 or 24 for the year, you feel like
you're going to lose, but it's actually
to keep the money in your possession so
you don't give all your money back to
prop firms or to the market.
I'm I'm I'm going to say this in terms
of options because I think it's
important. I'm going to say it every
episode until I actually do it. Please
buy Tom.
>> Please buy Tom. I'm I'm gonna give you a
prime example. Uh Coherent, which which
I I'll allude to a little bit later. I
just want to talk about their story
because they reported their earnings
last week and it was a great week in
terms of the AI infrastructure trade.
Obviously, Nibius and Cororeweave uh
Lmentum uh had a great week and then
Coherent uh and I was looking at
Coherent just because it's not part of
portfolio, but I'm interested in in
terms of photonics and I'll break that
down again in a little bit later. the
idea of volume. I wanted to see where
the volume was and I was looking like,
okay, short-term, long-term, what's the
short term, where are all the calls at,
right? So, if you look at an option
chain, you can see the volume. You can
also see the open interest. And I like
to look at those things because it tells
me, okay, number one, where are
institutions looking at and where are
they actually buying at? And
>> so 350 became a number. At the time,
Coherent was trading at like 342. 350 is
not far. Let's say if you're doing
something shortdated, I know a lot of my
guys are doing, you know, weeklies and
they're doing, you know, bi-weekly. So,
I'm like, "All right, let's look at this
350 number." Now, this is a prime
example. Coherent reported, amazing
quarter. Amazing. That looks like a good
quarter. Amazing quarter. They beat
>> They beat on adjusted EPS. Their data
center revenue, it rose by 60%. They did
a billion, right? A billion more than
they did a year ago. I watched coherent
drop from 347 to 305.
>> 305.
>> Now, if you were in that weekly, there's
no way to get that back.
>> Yeah, you're getting punished.
>> That implied volatility, that theta,
that decay is moving at such a fast rate
that that's a wash.
>> If you looked at what coherent did
today, [laughter]
this is a prime example of why time is
your greatest asset when it closed
today. Remember I told you 350 was the
number where I saw the open interest and
the value mat. Today it got up to 356. I
think it closed at 354. That jump from
one day which is which was Friday to
today is so drastic that if we had
another week right and Leapo again
that's the big story.
>> Yeah that's the big story.
>> Individually we're not doing it right.
We're like hey I got to do it out to
this week. Please use time as an asset
to help yourself and your portfolio.
>> One of the worst feelings in the world
is like taking a trade at like 245 and
[snorts]
close at 259 and you lose and then you
go to the aftermarket and it goes in the
direction you knew.
>> Brutal. Or you lose on Friday and got to
wait till Monday. Like time is so
important.
>> Whether Sunday Yeah.
>> Sunday at 700 you start seeing the
pre-market, you're like no way. No way.
Time has to be in your favor.
>> Time is all we have. Um, chart
breakdown.
>> Are we Yeah. Can Mike, can we pull this
chart up really quick?
And I shared this with Stock Club
earlier today, but I thought this is
really fascinating. Not not that one
other one. The pyramid, please. There we
go. Really quick, we talk a lot about AI
spend, but this came out in Wall Street
Journal. Um, AI spending is three
trillion higher than it seems. And I
want you guys to look on the right hand
side for the purchase commitments in
blue. Microsoft at 228, Alphabet. These
numbers are these are the numbers that
are not reported on the balance sheet.
Meta at 349, Alphabet at 811, Amazon at
130. So when people are telling you
about the circular investment and the
concern about AI, I thought this chart
was too important to not bring up. If
you look on the right hand side, you can
see $356 billion in long-term debt. On
the left hand side, $248 billion in
lease liabilities,
but if what's not on the balance sheet
to me is the most concerning thing. So,
I know for my charters and technicians,
we talk a lot about what we can see on
the chart, but I think this is a great
visual example of why so many people are
worried about the circular investment
and if everything is being reported
correctly and if there's a lot of debt
off the books at some point, the
chickens are going to come home to
roost. Uh, expect a correction in some
of these companies as a result. I
thought this was really fascinating.
>> Yeah, that capback spend is a real
thing. We talked about a trillion just
from those hyperscalers and
>> I heard somebody say, "Let's move away
from the word hyperscaler because nobody
knows what it means." Just say those
core four companies that are spending a
trillion institutional institutional
investing obviously we talked about last
week with Goldman and Black Rockck
coming into the space.
>> Um but uh it's
>> it's tough. It's tough. I I we we saw
Meta today and I know it's not on the
topic notes, but I think it's important.
They're one of those four companies when
we're talking about spend. They're at a
critical time and
Um I I I believe in Zuckerberg he'll
come out from this but the this social
media addiction piece that is happening
in California if they if the resolution
doesn't work in their favor then you're
going to start seeing that from state to
state and they may have to change how
they operate Instagram. Uh which I know
[snorts] both of them are going to be
testifying tomorrow in in the the case.
It'll be interesting to hear what they
have to say, but they they took a
beating today based on the potential
that this won't work in their favor and
they'll have to change maybe the
business model going forward. So, you
add that into the fact that they're
having a massive capex spin.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. It's an interesting time for Meta
still in the portfolio. Uh still think
it'll be obviously it's going to be a
long-term hurdle for me. It's been that
way, but this this is an interesting
time for the for a couple of reasons.
But if you're looking to be in the in
the the position also interesting time,
right? We've seen some deep pullbacks
and there might be some more to come in
the near future, but longterm I think
they figured this out.
>> As a trader on Meta, the thing that's
really fascinating,
Meta as a Fortune
8 company is gapping down like a penny
stock. So in November, it went from 741
to 680.
>> Then it gapped again. Well, it gapped up
in February, but then it gapped down in
May. For a company this size with its
revenue structure is really and I'll do
a charting segment next week, but it's
really interesting to see a company this
large gap 30 or 40 bucks
>> as if it's a lowflat subund million
>> company. So definitely they they're
going to have to make some changes to
their capex spend. And also coming off
of the metaverse misstep, there's a
couple of things they're going to have
to correct in the future in order for
the valuation to go back up to where it
should be.
>> Yeah. In a in a world where the majority
of the revenue is coming from
advertisement,
>> right? Like you can have products.
>> If something changes in the ad world, I
mean, they have three billion users,
right? Like they have that at their
disposal. They probably have the most
addictive product. You would I mean I
would argue with with obviously
>> for sure man.
>> How how do we add more things to the
revenue table in the near future? The
glasses kind of underperformed and we
have them and they're great. I love
them. It's just that the the general
public
>> they don't love them at the same rate
and now I'm seeing smear campaigns about
them.
>> It's it's uh again it's an interesting
time. They got a lot to figure out but
they got a great leadership team. I
think they will.
>> Yeah. I'll tell you from personal
experience being anti- Meta publicly
mistake.
[laughter]
Don't do it. Please don't. I went
through that so you don't have to go
through that. Even though they did
change the name from Facebook to Meta,
but shout out to everybody at HQ Hust
Yards. I love you dearly. Alvin,
[snorts]
>> good people over there.
>> Yeah, good people over there.
>> Yeah,
>> 100%. 6,700 people on the checkin on
this Monday. Hit the like button and and
share still. still reigns supreme when
it comes to market Monday's dynasty. Um,
okay. Next. Oh, next topic is a public
address. Wow. Time flies.
>> Yeah. I would I would like to take this
time to tell everybody. Chie, you have
the floor.
>> Yep. All yours, my brother.
[clears throat]
>> All right, let's get into it. Uh, it's
been a it's been an eventful month.
>> Yes. It's been an eventful month from
the Atlanta mayor situation to
Investfest to Post Investfest and here
we are. So,
we're not going to drag this out too
long, but um it's important to actually
have we're going to break this down
surgical for for the audience because
it's really important for people to
understand and we're going to have a
whole dialogue about this. So, let's
talk about Investfest, right?
Investfest.
There would be no invest Investfest
wouldn't be possible without Troy. He's
added so much value, without Mike
AB, Ian Dunlap, Matt Garland,
19 Keys.
There there's people that if it wasn't
for those people,
there would be no Investfest. Wouldn't
happen, right? it wouldn't happen at
all. You would you would there would
never be an Investfest if it wasn't for
the people that I just named and other
people as well.
But for me, Investfest is a little
different cuz everybody has their own
relationship with Investfest.
Investfest is something that is my idea,
right? So, it's a little different when
you come up with an idea in your head
and six years later it's 30,000 people.
Mhm.
>> That's a feeling that
very few people could probably
understand,
right? So, you you you you carry it a
little differently. And you know, I've
heard people say like, "Yo, Rashad's
crazy potentially."
But you but you gotta be crazy to think
that what you think in in your head
>> six years later can be a stadium
with no outside funding, with no
sponsorships, with no relationships,
with no connections, with no political
relationship.
just the empowerment of the people and
the support of everybody that's working
day in and day out. So in Investfest,
Investfest really a labor of love.
That's what people don't really fully
understand. Like we we promote
Investfest for one year. We already
planning for next year now.
>> We promote it for a year. We work on it
for a year. This is all us. Don't take
outside capital.
Everything you see is us. So
from a financial standpoint, this is
important for people to understand. It
makes no sense for us to do Investfest.
It's a lost leader. The amount of money
that we make from Investfest, right? To
be candid cuz Marketing Mondays, I owe
you guys a conversation cuz you are
actually family.
>> Yeah.
>> Me personally, I made more money on one
Micron call than what I made for
Investfest.
10,000 hours. By the way, all of the
mental
>> No, but it's important for people to
understand.
>> We don't make we don't we not making no
money on Investfest cuz it's a narrative
that well you guys are just doing it.
It's a grift. It's a money grab. It's a
there's a lot more easier ways for us to
make money. We know how to make money.
There's a lot more easier ways for us to
make money online or just through stock
investing, stock trading than
literally
doing something for a year with little
to no return. This is just a fact,
right? But you know who does benefit
from Investfest? The hundred speakers
that's put on stage that's spoken that
speak in front of people that they've
never had the opportunity to. The
largest crowds that they ever had in
their whole entire life. 400 vendors
that come to Investfest that sell their
products with no commission. 30 food
trucks that sell it that sell their food
for the whole entire weekend to 30,000
people with no commission. The the
hospitality club owners, restaurant
tours, the Uber drivers, the event
planners, the security, the hotel staff,
the you name it. It's obvious that has
an economic impact. It's 30,000 people.
Obviously, 30,000 people didn't come
from Atlanta. If you was at Investfest,
you met people from all over the world.
And how they do, how they measure
events is per day. So 30,000 people is
really 90,000 people. That's a 90,000
person event, right? So why am I saying
this? I'm saying this to say
this should it hit a little differently.
When you doing all of this, you're not
really making no money. It's a labor of
love. You discount tickets, you give
tickets away. You discount vendor
booths, you give vendor booths away. And
you have to hear [__] for eight weeks
about how it's a scam
>> about [clears throat] how we promote
scammers.
The day before Investfest, there's a
post that goes viral about the top 10
scammers that spoke at Investfest.
Nobody even took the Nobody even took
the time to even research that half of
that list never even stepped foot in
investfest ever. Five people never even
came to Investfest ever.
>> That's on the top 10 Investfest speaker
list. Two of those two of those people
have no idea why they even Why is Pinky
Cole a scammer? Cuz she didn't succeed
in business. She did succeed. She had a
$100 million valuation. There's ups and
downs. How who did she scam? Rick Ross.
So you have one person that spoke on a
podcast stage and then you have another
person I'm sorry what what Meek Mill say
lock him up if he ain't perfect. I'm
sorry. We had we have 400 speakers
throughout Investfest history and we had
two people that are now in federal
indictments.
Is that my fault? Is that Troy's fault?
Oh, we didn't properly vet. How could
you properly vet somebody that did
something after the fact?
But you ain't talk about 398 people that
we gave an opportunity to that we helped
change their life. But
accountability is very important. So
I'mma get to that. But I wanted to paint
the full picture because when you when
you winning you a win always feel like
you're losing. So to me it don't feel
like a win. People like yo you just came
off Investfest. The narrative should be
30,000 people and you right. But it hit
me a little different when I know I know
the work that we all put in to help
people to help black people
>> and to see negativity left and right on
my timeline and people talking about yo
I met this person at Investf fastest and
they took my website now we responsible
for attendees also and to see people and
then I'm seeing people in the comments
that I know personally that we help
that we that that we put on the show
champion [__] like this narrative like
that at Investfest. The day before
Investfest, it bothers me on a different
level. And it's human nature. You know,
you got a hundred people that say they
love you, the one person that comes up
and says that he hates you.
>> That's going to have a more vitrial
response than the 100 people that tell
you that they love you.
>> But that doesn't make it right. So, the
accountability is this.
>> No matter how much hate we get, I know
that the love is 10 times more. And
that's my fault for focusing on
negativity over positivity. So for this
community, because I'm not I'm not
talking to social media. I'm talking to
the people that's been rocking with us
from the beginning. That's Market
Mondays.
How how it came out from the clip very
insensitive. And I know that it could be
hurtful to somebody that's like, damn,
I've been riding with y'all from the
beginning and how could you say this?
So, I understand how people could have
taken that and I and I really do want to
say that if I hurt you in in that
commentary, I truly am sorry for that
because that wasn't that's what that
wasn't what it was for and that's not
it's not who it's directed to. And like
I said, that's something that I should
do a better job of focusing on the love.
But it, like I said, it just it hit a
little different when you built it.
Like, and it's like everybody's got
commentary, but it's like it's a little
different because we didn't raise money.
So, we don't we don't take money, we
make money. So, everything that we put
is on the on the line. So, it's a little
different when you put your own money on
the line.
>> We don't raise no money. We don't have
outside investors. We ain't crowdfund
for no money. I'm not knocking nobody
that does that, but I'm just saying you
you you going to fight a little
different for your [__] When it's your
child, when it's your child on trial,
you gonna fight a little different for
it because you know that you built that
from nothing. Impossible feat. It could
never happen again. It could never
happen again. when we had two cell
phones and we and we in a basement and 8
years later we we got 30,000 people and
we never took money and we never had no
real no real um financing behind us and
we never had no political connect and we
never had no real sponsorship. It's a
little different. So when somebody try
to tear that down for no reason, it hits
you a little different
>> and and and and that's my frustration.
And it's like we going to talk about
black people because it that's that's a
nuance conversation as well. But it it
hurts even more when you see black
people do it because it's like you doing
this. It don't got to be said that it's
for black people. You know it's for
black people. You already know that. And
that's that that's that's the part that
people don't I I don't never have to say
black earn your leisure. Black
investfest. You already know what it is.
You knew you had a You know you have a
safe space when you come to Investf
fastest because you black. You know you
got a safe space when you watch market
Mondays. We don't got to say it. It is
what it is. We like I said I ain't have
to learn culture. I am culture. This is
[__] that we grew up in. We ain't got to
like, you know what I'm saying?
Overemphasize. Yo, this is the black.
No, this is what it is. This is what it
is. Where I'mma go? Where I'mma run?
Where I'mma run to? Who I'mma run to?
You know what I'm saying? Like who I'mma
run to? I'm not going to be accepted
nowhere. So, it's like we we going to d
the sore before we bend the knee.
Believe that
>> because this [__] really means something
a little bit different to us. But like I
said, accountability is important as
well because you don't never want to
disrespect people that support you.
>> And sometimes in your anger,
you drag people into it that don't
deserve it. And the people that watch
Market Mondays, they don't deserve it.
People that watch Blackout, they don't
deserve it. People that's been rocking
with us from day one, they don't deserve
it. But I just really want y'all to
understand. Y'all tell me like, "Yo, if
you don't want to do InvestFest, we
don't have to do Investf Fest. It won't
hurt us financially. I'm just being
honest. I'm not I'm not trying to brag,
boast. I'm just completely being honest.
It's going to hurt other people more
than it hurts us. That's just a fact. If
we have a $70 million economic impact,
you obviously know if we don't do the
event, it's going to hurt other people
more than it hurts us." And that's when
people like, "Yo, he's antilack." We've
done more for black people than a lot of
organizations. I will put us up against
anybody. Over the course of the eight
years, we've highlighted 520 black
entrepreneurs. We don't got to say it's
black. We've highlighted 520 black
entrepreneurs that helped change
people's life. No back.
>> Over the course of the last eight years,
we've made countless people millionaires
from watching our show. That's a fact.
For free information over the we we've
opened up brokerage accounts. We've
changed people's dynamics. We've made
people buy homes. We clean people's
credit just from the free information
that we provided on the show. And that's
a fact. So you a political pundit or
whatever and I don't see anybody
helping. Like they somebody what have
you done for black people? That's what
we've done for black people. What have
y'all done for Atlanta? That's what we
did for Atlanta. In three days we have
more of an economic impact than some
people have in their whole entire life.
That is a fact. That's not an opinion.
That's a fact.
That is a fact. So y'all saying yo, he's
antilack. How? All we did was help black
people from the beginning for free. All
we did was help black people. All we
continue to do is help black people. But
it's extremely frustrating when you see
black people. And even this, you see
Investfest with 30,000 people. It's
never been done before. It will never be
done.
It took all of these commentators to
start commentating when I said something
about something else that went viral.
That's what got the attention. Right
now, we got 87 7,800 people in here.
It's the most people we had all year.
We've been giving information for free
all year. It took 7,800 people to come
when we talking about some [__]
That's why I wore this t-shirt. This
t-shirt come from my iPhone. I made this
t-shirt with my iPhone. This is our
first logo. This is my emoji and Troy's
emoji. I made it with my iPhone. This
[__] from This [__] really from the
ground up. This [__] really from the
ground up. Like for real. For real. Like
I don't think like people fully
understand like this [__] this [__]
built from the ground up. So it's going
to hit a little different when
somebody's talking some [__] You
going to fight a little bit different.
You're going to feel you going get a
little They're like, "Yo, you're too
emotional." Yeah. Because it's it it
means a little bit more to me,
>> my baby.
>> It means a little bit more to me. And
and that's the part that you'll probably
never understand if you haven't built
it. If you haven't built something, it's
going to be hard for you to understand.
You're going to be you're going to be
able to let it go. You're going to be
able to let people throw dirt on your
name. you gonna be able to let people
tarnish your [__] because it don't mean
nothing to you. It's it's outside
capital. It's other people's
investments. It's yet but when it when
you put your own money up in your own
time, it's gonna feel a little
different.
And the last thing I say is like this
as far as like when you say the black
thing, that's why, like I said, we don't
never got to say that we black anything.
We've done more for our community than I
would argue mostly anybody.
That's a fact because we we did the most
important thing and made people money. I
know somebody that tried to call one of
my friends and tell him like, "Yo, you
need to get he said, "Yo, I don't care
what you tell me. They made me $2
million.
It's going to be hard for me to ever go
against the Bros because they literally
made me $2 million." That's what that's
what he that's that was his response.
So, I'm looking at it like this.
You don't, it's hard to to to to
communicate some things, but they
minimize things by language. So when
they say, "Oh, this is the biggest black
financial literacy event." What does
that even mean? You segmented it in so
many different categories that it
doesn't mean anything anymore. Say what
it is. It's the one of the biggest
business events in the world because
that's what it is. Now that's a
different level of credibility. Now
that's a different level of sponsorship.
Now that's a different level of growth.
When it becomes when it how it is now as
a influencer event, it's a feel-good
community event. Then it's just it goes
on social, it goes viral, it's good for
the moment. Nah. And that's another
thing. And now I'm not happy with 30,000
cuz I want more.
>> And and it's not I want more for me. I
want it to be one of the biggest
business events in the world. So when
Julian Brown gets off stage, he got $20
million waiting for him cuz that's what
happened if he was at Davos. Uhhuh.
>> That's what happened if he was at
Milkin.
So y'all don't understand. It's not even
about us. When when we have a different
lens, this whole [__] is going to
change. That's the part that's
dangerous. Being called the financial
literacy event for black people that's
in the southeast. That's not dangerous.
Even the word financial literacy is a
dangerous word because they use that as
a connotation of charity of people that
are not educated of people that's like,
"Oh, this is just community give back."
No, call it what it is. It's business
and and it's and it's economics
>> and it's investing. We playing at the
highest level possible. That's how we
playing it. And everybody not going to
understand your vision and that's fine.
And like I said, maybe I am crazy, but I
got to be crazy to think about some [__]
that's going to turn into something like
that six years later. So, [__] it. roll
the dice because we've been rolling the
dice our whole life anyway. So yeah, I'm
looking at I'm not happy with 30,000
people. I want I want it to be regarded
as the World Economic Forum. I want it
to be regarded as the Milkham
Conference. That's when you going to see
the entrepreneurs really walking out of
there with $5 million because all the
hedge funds got to come there.
>> They don't look at it like that right
now. They don't. And the more y'all tear
it down, the the more you're hurting
your own ecosystem because y'all talking
about all this black black. NOBODY PUT
19 keys on stage except for us. THAT'S A
FACT. NOBODY PUT QUEEN OF FOUR on stage
except for us. That is a fact. Nobody's
putting Yaki Awaken on stage except for
us. That's a fact. Derek Falcon came
home from doing a 12ear stretch. He's on
our stage. We putting brothers on stage
that would never get an opportunity
ever, ever in life. And shout out to
Isaac Hayes. We spoke, you know, I I had
some issues with the commentary that he
said cuz I felt like we helped him a
lot. But he said something that was
really insightful. He's like, "Yo, I
never been on Tech Crunch. I never been
on." And I said, "What? You been on Earn
Your Leisure?" Eight times.
Eight times between Blackout, Market
Mondays, Investfest, and and and and
Market and um and Earn Your Leisure.
eight times.
Who put SpurGo on on who put Miss
Business? We seen her business grow.
We grew together. That's a direct
correlation. Ask her. Ask her. Ask 19
keys if you think. Ask him how many how
many book How many people book him? Ask
him. Ask him. Ask him who set the
booking rate for him.
So, we put $500,000 into black
entrepreneurs within the last two years
just from a pitch competition. Shout out
to Paul Judge.
So, I think we really just got to have,
you know, just a more critical lens of
how we look at things. But like I said,
accountability is important and I do
want to take responsibility for my
words. So, I do apologize to anybody
that was offended. Of course, we not
going against black people. Like I said,
who I'mma go against? My name is Rashad
Bal. where I'mma go. Everybody know I'm
black. That's obvious. [laughter]
>> You know what I'm saying? But it's just
on arrival. On arrival. You think And
that's the thing, too. It wasn't We
wasn't made by no political force. We're
not elitist. We wasn't made by no
political force. We wasn't made by no
corporation. We wasn't made by nothing.
We was we we powered by the people and
empowered by God. So, that's another
thing. We can never be cancelled. I'm
sorry. I know it's a lot of think pieces
and they like we can never be cancelled
because we powered by the people and we
empowered by God. And when you powered
by the people and you empowered by God,
you can never be cancelled. You can
never be cancelled. Nobody nothing can
ever go against you. No weapon shall
ever prosper.
So,
>> Amen.
>> I don't want to take too much time. I
know some people really wanted me to go
full shotty mode. And and the last thing
I'll say is this. For the people that
took the time to try to pick us apart, I
know a lot of it is jealousy and envy
and hatred.
And I and I and trust me, I had a whole
script. I was gonna go at you guys
personally and I was gonna bring up
stuff that I know in business and I was
gonna bring up a lot of stuff because
like I said when you when you put your
track record but
>> essentially I'm asking for grace
>> and it would it would be it would be
misguided for me to ask for grace and
not to provide grace even for people
that have no good intentions for us at
all. So, I'm not even gonna respond to
the 500 videos that I saw that were pure
purely done to d to try to destroy us.
I'mma provide grace for people that
didn't even ask for grace because
essentially we all going to need grace
at at some point in time. We all going
to make a mistake and we all going to
need grace. And I rather I rather end it
on a high note than go low.
I'm happy to see you there. I'm happy to
see you. And for all of those who
thought that messaging me or calling me
was a was a great way to get the message
through to Rashad, I I want to let you
all know that before you guys have a
conversation or decide to text him, we
have a conversation because we brothers.
So, if there's something that I see, we
going to have a conversation cuz if it's
affecting him, then it's going to affect
me and it's going to affect us as
brothers and friends, but it also going
to affect business. So, we going to have
our conversations. You know what I'm
saying? I told him and he kind of
alluded to, yo, protect your peace at
all cost because you're having
conversations with people who don't
understand and they can't get a full
context of what you're trying to explain
in a five minute clip. And so, protect
your peace. So, that that piece is the
most important thing. Obviously, we've
been purposed to do a job. We have a
mission. We don't have to do it, but we
have to do it. And I by that I mean,
yeah, could we be in front of a computer
and doing things and of course, but we
have to do it because we've been on
ordained to do it. This is our mission.
This is our purpose. And we've been
saying that since day one and we going
to continue to say it, right? Cuz
sometimes
your purpose is put there for you to
just follow the footsteps. And that's
all we've been doing. Him in finance for
his whole life, right? Me in education,
us together as financial education. And
we going to keep that mission going. and
everybody here, we salute you and we
applaud you for number one executing on
information, but taking time out to
receive the information, but also
bringing other people in, right? Because
when we started this, it wasn't 8,000
people here. When we started Marketing
Mondays, we was like, "Yo, if we get a
thousand people in here,
>> yeah, I was happy. We got to 800.
>> We've grown and y'all grown with us and
y'all made money and y'all told other
people about the information and that's
how we scale and we gonna continue to
scale together, right? Like we're better
together. We'll build together. People
saying things, cool. Focus on the people
that are focusing on us. And that's what
we continue to do. Love is love. Y'all
know that.
>> And I want to thank y'all brothers for
just being solid. You, Ian, Mike. Nobody
crossed enemy lines. Nobody broke the
ranks. And that's something I can't say
for everybody, but the the the core
group,
y'all never turned your back, never
wavered in the face of adversity. And
that's what real brotherhood is about.
You're not always going to agree with
your brother. Even sometimes your
brother going to get you into some [__]
but you got to see it through. We going
to see this mission through. And like I
said, we going we going to die on the
sword before we bend the knee cuz we
believe in this [__] and we want to help
people. So this is William Wallace. We
going we going to wave the flag and we
going to go three verse 30,000 if we got
to on some warrior [__]
Brave Hearts,
>> [__] it. [laughter]
>> We come out victorious or we don't come
out. We come out victorious or we don't
come out at all.
>> That's it. That's That's the type of
tower of war.
>> Warriors,
>> I commend your transparency cuz I I
didn't even think you was going to go
that route and reveal some of the inside
ball. Um I'll say too, um I should have
protected you better on Wednesday.
That's my fault. But we both exhausted.
But as brothers,
I should have either stepped in more say
take that [__] out. So for that, I
apologize.
>> Um,
>> no. No. It's all good, bro. It's Mike's
fault. Actually, he's the editor. I told
him about that. He's the editor. He
supposed to actually watch [laughter]
to lock up. Bring But as a as a man,
everything on earth is your fault. So,
I'm going take responsibility for also
and not to
>> make any concessions. Mike, I love you.
>> Also,
>> you just changed the title. You changed
the topic. It's always Mike's fault.
[laughter]
>> Oh, God. New show coming soon. Always
Mike.
>> New topic. New topic.
>> Yeah. [laughter] So, but also be mind be
mindful of the paid campaigns against
Okay, I'mma be real. I'm seeing now it
go from that to y'all hate Martha's
Vineyard
to
don't don't turn on Isaiah Martin and
Deontay Cow. I'm begging y'all. Every
everything black it seems to go train
and y'all don't like when that
administration is paying y'all some of
y'all to do that.
>> Oh man.
>> And and and I'll say this, the last
thing I'll say is um I was always taught
never destroy something unless you have
something better to replace it. So all
of you social media commentaries and all
of you
>> No, no, no. But I'm just saying from the
audience standpoint, right? You really
got to question because it's like, okay,
if we go away, if we go away today,
>> if Investfest goes away today,
>> how many people are hurt by that?
>> Sometimes we think we hurting we hurting
the people, but you're actually hurting
a whole ecosystem and community with no
with no structure in place to replace
it.
>> Investfest has never been anything like
Investfest before.
No. Ever. Ever. Never. Ever. Ever.
Never. So, okay. You you you hate us so
much that your your number one purpose
is try to destroy it. What is in replace
of it? You don't have any replacement
for it. How many people suffer from that
loss? A lot. A lot. I met a brother in
Atlanta who was doing a he was working
back on the A. He said, "Yo, every time
every time you come to Atlanta, I make
$3,000."
He said, "Yo, please don't ever stop. I
make $3,000. That's my rent for the
month. I make in three days.
>> I make $3,000 in three days. He's like,
I love I love this [__] I love when
y'all come.
>> So,
>> and maybe once that we can have a
conversation around what it takes to do
events because even that in in our
space, it's not cheap. Kudos to Dave
Shans and everybody who threw event like
the costs are
so cumbersome. They don't even want the
information to be out to the public to
be honest.
It's just on AV.
>> That's a That's a
>> on audio visual stage.
>> That's a fact.
>> Can we do Can we do something?
>> But you know what, man? We love you
though. But but I just want to say this
though cuz like I said, I I
>> even my dad told me, Troy tell me all
the time, you got to focus more on
positivity than negativity. That's
that's my resolution for the rest of the
year and going forward.
>> So gratitude is a major key. I want to
say thank you to everybody that watches
Market Mondays from the beginning.
Everybody that's been championing us,
everybody that, you know, tells a friend
to tell a friend, the hate does bother
me. I'm gonna be honest with you, but
I'm I'mma focus my energy on the love.
I'm not even going to worry about the
hate. You make y'all make as many
reaction videos as you want. Call us
scammers. Say the whole thing. Say
whatever you want. Say whatever you
want. I'm never going to respond to you
guys ever again. And that's my fault for
even taking my eye off of the off of the
ball. Pause. But thank you guys. We
don't we don't we don't take you for
granted. And for the rest of the show
tonight,
>> we going to give you as much value as
possible so you can make as much money
as possible. Shout out to Chris S.
>> A real one.
Yo,
>> can we put
>> that That takes uh growth. Pause. That
takes maturity too though, right? So
like to watch my brother mature, to to
speak candidly, to speak from his heart,
it takes a lot. It's not an easy thing
to do. I I just said, "Can we do Can we
do something real quick?"
>> For sure.
>> Can we get back to this money talk?
>> Big facts. Let's get to this money talk.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
Let's talk about that. Let's get to this
money.
>> Um for those of you who are concerned
about Micron and if it's going to
continue to rise, I I would say don't be
worried. Um next week I'm going to do a
full presentation on pricing. If it gets
back down to the 854 or 85615 level, I
really love it. I'm not saying that it
will, but it's a area that I'm
personally looking for. Um, and then
maybe even at
I don't know it
91575.
I really like it. The thing I want to
reiterate though is even though it's won
up a lot, there's more room for it to
grow. And it reminds me of Nvidia early
post 2021 when it had this amazing year.
It started to pull back and people will
lose faith in it. And I'm like, okay, it
may not give you a,000% return, but
there's room for 30 and 50 and 70% runs.
So stay locked in. Um, hold, but more
importantly, hold these assets for 5
years. A lot of you are being tricked
out of your spot by thinking about two
or three years, and you're like, well, I
don't have two to three years. You don't
have any other option other than holding
for a long period of time because the
truth is you haven't got to the wealth
number that you want because you won't
hold an asset that means a lot for a
long enough period of time. So I think
Micron um is still incredibly valuable.
I would not begin to I I've even seen
some posts about shortening the memory
sector. I know Michael Bur is on his
>> he got his face beaten last week.
[laughter] He shorted Nibius. How did
that go? But even with that, you you
never know a person's time horizon.
>> Yeah.
>> And also, there's a lot of money in
being a contrarian cuz you can get
funding. Not saying that my kids, but
you can get funding from being a
contrarian.
>> So, he may have a short only fund
personally and a long only fund, but the
traction comes from talking about the
shortening of it. Don't short the memory
sector. That's my PSA for this week.
>> I would say I'm I'mma go out a little
further. Uh Ian, I'm
>> But here's the craziest [__] Yo, 500
people just left the chat after we got
talking about like we now we talking
about some [__] that really gonna make
people
>> only worried about the convers
that still want to make some money. I'm
gonna go out even further. Ian, I'm
gonna say this. I think Micron is
undervalued even at this number.
>> I agree.
>> If you look at it P ratio, if you look
at it valuation, it's actually
undervalued. And why I was watching it
last week was because it was important
to see it fully recover. not back to its
all-time high, but at least above some
of its EMAs. And so, I was watching the
72. I'm like, yo, if it gets to the 72,
where's the next, oh, can it get to his
50? And now you're starting to see cons
consolidation outside of the 400 of the
200, the 50, they're all in that
convergence side where it's like, all
right, well, if we clear this one,
what's next? 966 was that last hurdle
for me on Friday. So, when we close
above 972, I said, look, we're going to
have an upward trend happening very
shortly here in Micron. Obviously the
news that came from Apple and uh Lutnik
saying that you know they don't want
Apple using foreign memory chips that's
going to help to stop the investors day
from Sanders which happened Thursday
helped the momentum as well. Nvidia is
going to be reporting next week which
will help the sector as well. We saw
demand from Cororeweave. We saw demand
from all of the AI infrastructures and
and plays inside of the space have
appreciated. Micron crossing that
threshold was the sign for me. I'm like,
"All right, look, I still have the price
target at 1,600 for the end of the year.
I still have it there,
>> right?" And so, I'm looking at it. I'm
like, "Well, if we cross this this 966
number, well, where do we go?" Well, the
next stop is let's go retest the alltime
highs over up at what is it? 1250.
Where' it get to in June?
>> Yeah, 1255. Y
>> 1255. So, can we get there? I think we
can. The momentum is looking like it's
headed that way. We have some traction.
Again, end of this week could be a big
catalyst event as well. I I still love
it at this number. I've loved it since
it was $86. I loved it at $100. I still
think we're undervalued based on the
demand that we're seeing from every
company that's reported. And I think
that's key, right? Do you have to look
at the earnings report of companies
you're not invested in? Well, some
people will tell you no, I don't really
have an interest in it. But you should
because those companies will tell you
the demand. It'll tell you if the story
has been consistent. It will tell you
where we're headed. Right? So when we
see that uh GPUs are in demand or when
AMD is saying, "Hey, our CPU sector is
really thriving, all those components
are going to need that bottleneck called
memory." We're going to I'm going to
break down something probably next week,
the the next layer inside of the AI
infrastructure, but it's going to need
it. And so when we see Sandis rise,
right, it felt like they all moved
together and we're seeing that momentum
again.
>> We hit a correction and we know on the
other side of that correction is growth.
So we had a a higher low. Now, let's go
see if we can some hit some higher
highs. I still obviously [clears throat]
I love Micron. I got a stack of calls
inside of Micron. Obviously, I got a
bunch of shares as well. I I think we're
undervalued. I think I think we're going
we're going to higher higher numbers uh
before the year's out.
>> I think um in September, October, if we
hit that 8209 level, it's a great area
to invest, hold for the long term. and
the AI spin, the memory sector is
probably one of the few that won't be
affected. Also, uh Rashad, I want to
tell you those that leave are a
blessing. I'll say for me personally,
anybody who was not loyal to me in Red
Panda, they didn't make more money
after. If I made you money, please put
yes in chat. I can pull up screenshots
forever of people who made two, three,
four, 500,000, let alone the millions
that I had on stage. And for all the new
red pad the millionaires, the blessing
often is the people who leave.
>> Mhm.
>> Yeah.
>> They got what they they got what they
came for. All right. Cool. Y'all deserve
whatever happens after that. [laughter]
>> Well, a shout out to my brother Stakes
too out in out in Watts.
>> Hey, real one.
>> Real one. Real one.
>> A real one from day one. Yeah. Compar
comparison tool breakdown.
>> Let's skip that. I want to do that next
week. I want to do the review my
portfolio. I think that's a new segment.
>> Let's do Let's do the review my
portfolio. Also before we go, um
speaking of Red Panda Millionaire, shout
out to the Red Panda Rebellion. We said
last week we opened up 25 slots for the
the annual, you know, summer deal that
we do um with Red Panda, three-year
access for the price of one year. U
we've extended it for 10 10 more slots.
It was a high level of demand as you can
imagine. So, we have 10, we opened up 10
more slots for three-year access to Red
Panda for the price of one year. You can
go to ianinvest.com if you if you're
interested in that. Um, first come,
first serve. And that's Red Panda is the
community that Ian has where he actually
tells you where to buy the stocks, like
what price to buy the stocks. They also
have monthly calls. Um he gives you the
the the the sniper program for a year
which actually gives you the fundamental
uh startup to actually start trading
futures. Um 10 stocks to buy the watch
list. It's the whole thing. It's it's
the setup for people that's serious for
long-term holds to make tremendous
amounts of money because the most
important thing in investing is where
you buy not necessarily what you buy.
That goes back to the micron call. If
you brought Micron at his high, you're
still down.
>> If you bought Micron when we got it,
you're up, you know, 3,000%.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> So, it it it all depends. So,
ianinvest.com.
10 more slots have been opened for
three-year access. We did 25 slots. So,
it's going to be a cohort of 35 people.
35 people. 10 slots is open. First come,
first serve. Go to Ianinvest.com.
Let's go to review my portfolio.
>> Ian, real quick. real quick. Ian, we got
the September date for for the the
class.
>> Um, let me look at the calendar right
now. Shout out to Shauna for always
being super dope and supportive. Uh, the
20th of September.
>> All right, I'm Let's do this. Let's do
this right here. Say this is a family. I
I want to join that class. I want to
come to that class and uh let you know
how we go back and forth.
>> Yeah. Yeah, for sure.
>> Let's Let's do Let's Let's do some
options. Let's do some futures together
and let's give the people as much value
as possible.
>> Yeah, I'm down. I'm down for that
thousand%. Everyone,
>> the last one.
>> So, this is Red Panda got said this
before anyone did
>> for sure.
>> That's a lot a lot of coin being made.
Yes. Yes. So, um and for everyone who
keep asking about the scholarship,
market Mondays is a scholarship and a
hedge fund. That's the part I want to
say for the people who was messaging me
saying we need a cohort and we need an
investment fund. This is the investment
fund here already. For the person who
asking does Micron going to go go down
to 500? If Micron goes down to 500,
every other company on earth is going to
drop 35%. I don't think so.
>> Yeah, that if it does, it's going to be
blood on the street.
>> A lot of blood is going to be
splattered. Yeah. Micron 500 is not
something you want to see. So let's not
even speak it,
>> right? But that it's interesting when we
used to talk about it after they they
reported in June blowout quarter we saw
the pullback we saw the correction the
demand has actually increased
>> right so when we're talking about open
source but people think oh open source
that's going to affect the way that
business is done because no more people
are going to be using artificial
intelligence if we have open source more
people are going to mean there's going
to be more memory that's going to be
needed because there's more users being
uh in the space I I watched you know one
of the founders of Open AI this morning
on CNBC. He said, "Yeah, we got a
billion people a month.
>> We're doing a and we're increasing."
Anthrop is about to come online. We want
to see their numbers. These are
>> these are astronomical numbers. And this
bottleneck
sold out for 26. We knew that.
>> They said mid 27. Now it's looking like
we're sold out till 2028. And so again,
when you're sold out and you're in high
demand, you control pricing. So I I I I
see this continuing to run. And like
inflation and pricing after co once you
see an increase of pricing by 3x a
company's not bringing the prices back
now. Apple learned this the hard way.
That's why I be so hard on them. But
shout out to everybody at HQ. You could
have bought one of these memory
companies for cheap or one of these AI
companies for cheap and now you're kind
of being priced out and now you don't
have pole position to tell them what to
do. So
>> no they're they're not coming down for
sure.
>> Yeah, man.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. All right. Let's let's let's let's
review the portfolio
>> new segment.
>> Which one you want to do?
>> You know what? Let let's start with Oh,
wow. My phone just cut my iPad just cut
off. Let's start with this one here. It
says uh
I'm in Canada.
>> This is my portfolio. Nvidia,
>> VFV
>> and VQT. I believe the US equivalents
are VFV and VEQT.
are V. I guess this is VTI.
>> Yeah.
>> Do you like it or would you do something
different?
>> I like it as a base. Um, shout out to
all the Toronto fam and the Canadian
listeners.
>> Shout out to the shout out to the
Toronto family
>> always
>> at all times. Um, I'm really big on
hyper concentration,
but I do think you need a fourth
selection here. Not only for
diversification, but for also for
upside. Like I think for the foreseeable
future, maybe three or four years, I
think Nvidia is going to be between,
let's say, 15 and 35%. I do think you
need a company that can grow. um a
micron and sand disk isn't gonna be
thrown around all the time, but um a
company that can get you maybe 40 to 50%
gain is great. Now, if you never off
this portfolio, life will be fine.
You're going to do great. You have very
little draw down to worry about. You'll
be fine. But I would add probably one
more stock to it to round it out to give
you a little bit of uh protection on
downside draw down.
>> All right, this is this I like this one
here. All right, this person says
Nvidia, they have 390 shares. VO 101
shares, VTI 101 shares. Individual
equity, they have Robin Hood. And then
they have DRAM, uh, little like 70 71
shares, and then one share of Visa,
which is a new position. What you think
about this portfolio?
>> Uh, damn near perfect. Like I I can't
argue. Nvidia 390 shares. They've had
them for a while. Love it. VO love, VTI
love, DRAMM love. I think Visa is
undervalued, but given where the global
economy is, the level of debt, I think
uh they I think they may slide down to
like 340 453 and then bounce up. Um I
will probably add some there, but in
terms of how they currently have their
portfolio calibrated, I love it. I would
give it a A+ uh performance for sure.
>> All right. All right. Now, this one's
interesting.
This one's interesting. All right. Let's
start with this. All right. So, they
have AM. They have ARM G, which is a
double lev uh ARM. It's a $45 call.
>> They have RAM, which is a double lev uh
DRAM,
>> $28 call. SoFi at $35 call. SoFi is like
trending at that $20 line. It's just
kind of been there. uh AS uh and we
spoke about that when we're talking
about the space economy uh and their
partnership with Google 80 shares,
Microsoft 30 shares, Google 30 shares,
Nvidia 20 30 shares, uh DRAM 20 shares
and a 20 shares. What are your thoughts
on this portfolio and then I got some
thoughts after you have your
>> for sure because I think we're thinking
the same thing. A I'm not an options
expert, but when I looked, I don't like
the collection of tradable assets that
they have in that call collection. But
my more importantly though, when a
person leads with a trading portfolio,
that always scares me. For me, the
long-term equities have to lead if you
want to build wealth. And for those who
say, well, I want to build wealth. I
just want to flip. You won't be able to
flip unless you have a great foundation
there. ESTs, not bad. Microsoft solid.
Google, great. Nvidia, great. AP, great
>> DRAM. So, that portion of the portfolio
I like.
>> Yeah.
>> But, but now I need you to guide them on
how you would recalibrate that option
side. And once again, when you're
talking about like the trades are not a
portfolio.
>> I know people have recalibrated it, but
it's not a long-term asset because once
it hits the the expiry period, like
that's why same for futures. Like, I
don't care how well you can trade. It's
technically not a asset no matter how
much money you make. So what would you
have them do different there?
>> Yeah, I I would build out my portfolio.
Number one, I have the equity. So I do
like this side of it. So like Nvidia,
Google, Microsoft, that's a solid core
three ATS.
I I understand it. That's the largest
allocation here. But rather than having
just random calls here, right? You have
ARM, but you don't have any shares of
ARM. Like I would build my portfolio of
that, right? Like number one, do I own
the equity first? Right? So everybody
knows Nvidia is my largest shareholder
in my portfolio. Google I have share all
the companies pretty much. Um I have
shares of Sandis I I don't have shares
but the call is sold early. It's like a
2:30 call for December of 28.
>> Okay.
>> So you can understand like I could
exercise against shares there. I don't
know if I will. Um but this the calls
that you do have two of them are double
leveraged
>> and double leverage
>> right? So you you have drama there's
drama in the portfolio but there's DAM
in the portfolio but when we talked
about DRAM when it was a week old that
would have been the time to say okay let
me perhaps get an option call that is
out to next year on it then it ran up to
40 we did another one at 33
>> there's another time it ran all the way
up to 80 a lot of people took their 100%
profits so if you have shares in some of
these equities that would be where I
would start in terms of looking at calls
for them so like the double leverage
Again, there's a step-by-step guide I
gave to what you should be looking at
before doing the double leverage. I
think most people look at and say, "Oh
my gosh, I can make the most money if
this goes up." But the same goes down.
Yeah. On the downside, right? And so, we
just got to be mindful of that. And if
you are going to do these double
leverage calls,
>> buy time, please buy time because
expedite on the way down, but also
expedite it on the way up. Um, so it's
important to know that, but I would
definitely have ETFs as part of the
options calls that I have. If you go
back to 2021,
my original core ETFs were SMH, XK, XLY.
Then let's build on top of that, right?
We got our our core four four legs. At
the time, I had to figure out what the
fourth one was. Now we got our core. Now
we can put individual equities on top.
Whether it's Nvidia, it's AMD, it's
Apple, it's Microsoft, it's Google. At
the time it was Tesla. build on top of
that. This one kind of looks like I want
to do my portfolio in a way that I have
equity shares, but I also want to do
calls and it's kind of like all over the
place. I would fine tune this. But the
fact that you have shares is I like
>> is amazing.
>> I would fine tune the options though.
>> Rashad, what you think about the last
one?
I would um
definitely, you know, I I think that for
every option that you have, you should
have three stocks.
>> That's a great ratio.
>> Three to one ratio in your portfolio
because like you said, a lot of people
was having a portfolio with options.
>> Yeah.
>> You like I got $80,000 invested in the
market. What's what's your what's your
breakdown? I got a $20,000 micron call.
I got a $10,000 zero day option with
spy. I got a a medical.
I'm like, okay, that's 70,000. And then
they're like, oh yeah, I got 10,000 in
V.
>> That's happening a lot because the thing
that's happening more than people say
>> you want I get it. It's like, yo, I need
to I need to get rich now. I need to get
rich now. And and obviously this is
going to give me a lot more leverage.
But when you play that game,
a you can't think straight because
you got too much leveraged
>> and you can lose your whole portfolio
very quickly. Um, so it's going to take
a little bit longer, but you should
always build your portfolio around
long-term buying holes. 3 to one is my
30% of your portfolio.
I don't know, man. If you got more than
that, you you you in uh you're
dangerous.
>> You'll be [__] I'mma be honest.
>> They just show with Leopold Quiet
Witching. They can maneuver the pricing
around for you to be underwater and then
when expiration hits, it flies up in
your favor. It It's a horrible feeling
to not have enough time on your side.
>> Yeah. And and that is the piece. That's
why I I led with that as the the fact of
the week like please make sure you have
it because when you don't I remember
shout out to L Tucker he told me early
he's like look just don't lose your
shirt doing this I'm like what you mean
he was like yo you could lose everything
including your shirt
>> so be be mindful of that right so that's
why you got to have the fundamental have
your base that's important then if you
want to explore and say hey I'm already
long-term holding I got whatever that
metric is is it 10 is it 20 is it 50
shares is it 100 is it a thousand
shares, then start looking at, you know,
okay, I I might do an option call in
here. That's longterm in terms of option
world, right? Longterm is relative,
right? Because most of these contracts
go out to two and a half years. But in
that space, that's a lot of time. And
what you're not realizing is that these
whales, right? If you ever listen to the
CBOE uh report now, that's part of a CMC
after 4:00.
>> They're waiting for y'all to do the
dailies and they're waiting for y'all to
do the weeklies and the
>> bi-weekly. Right. Yep.
>> So they can manip allegedly manipulate
it
>> the money in. Right. We've been watching
the news lately.
>> Not only are equities going to be able
to be traded 24 hours.
>> Options.
>> Yeah.
>> From 9:00 p.m. to 4. It's not that far
away. And I'm telling you, it's not for
your benefit. [laughter] As a person
that could trade futures overnight for
the last 11 years, I s like listen
American open 8:30 to 9:30
hard stop 2:45 to 3 central
5 to 6 London open. Just because it's
open all night doesn't mean it's
liquidity all night and it doesn't mean
it's in your favor. You're going to get
whipped out of your positions.
>> Do not overtrade. That's what they so
that think about the liquidity that's
going to come into the space. Yeah.
>> When people are allowed to do that and
that becomes very speculative because
people are watching things after hours
and they're like how do I participate?
Why can't I participate?
>> Now when people can't do it, it it feels
like 2017 again where it was like we
were watching Ethereum and like wait
this Bitcoin and we couldn't sleep
because we was just so fascinated.
>> Yeah. You can just trace something at
any time of the day and you can't sleep
because when you wake up you're like oh
my god I should jump three cent
>> and like that's what the market becomes.
Oh my
>> oh my.
>> And yeah somebody put in chat you should
definitely have different accounts. You
put one option trading futures whatever
you trade have a trading account and
then have an investment long-term buy
and hold account. You should honestly
have a few accounts. You should have a
retirement account.
>> You [snorts] should have a retirement
account. You should have a trading
account. You should have a brokerage
account. So yeah, don't don't coingle
and and that works especially with you
know obviously the things we've been
learning with you know using your
portfolio to your advantage. Um number
one Erade and I'll just say it I don't
get paid by any of these companies but
that's my options account. I have a
Charles Schwab account that has just
individual equity. So I got my AMD
shares there, my uh Apple shares in
there, Microsoft shares in there and
then I just have my index account. So
like V uh VTI that's in my Fidelity
account. So those are three different
accounts. I know we're not co-mingling.
>> Separate. Yeah. Yeah.
>> And everything's separate.
>> Um
>> somebody asked, "What should the new
hours be?" The new hours should not
change. Just because you have more
options to trade does not mean you need
to fall for the trap. It's a snare.
They're not putting out single stock
futures and more trading time for your
benefit. They're not.
>> They're not. Absolutely not. Um, new ETF
alert.
>> New ETF alert. I want y'all to write
this down. Put this in your notes. I
feel like we about to have another
moment. Um, and if you've been watching
ETFs, it's interesting. I I was
listening to uh Josh Brown. They were
talking about ETFs and the amount of
ETFs that have come online in the past
six years.
>> Insane.
>> I had no idea. Right. So, I think in
2021 there were 206
ETFs in existence. Last year alone, 960
were created. And this year they said
that they're going to pass that number.
So you're talking about over 2,000 ETFs
in the past three years,
>> which tells me index funds and mutual
funds. That's going to be tough. That's
going to be tough because these more
products are being created. But the new
ETF that I'm looking at is it and it's
something that just came online uh on
August 6th goes back into the story
where we were talking about this AI
infrastructure space and the idea of how
information and data is going to travel
and
>> you picking my baby.
>> Oh, am I? I don't know. We're talking
about photonics. And so photonix really
just means how data it's using light to
transfer data which makes it a lot
faster, more efficient. And that is
where it's headed in terms of data
transfer inside of the actual data
centers. So if you look at Nvidia, their
partnership with GLW, Apple's
partnership with GLW, which is cornering
for those not in the know, if you watch
what uh Nvidia has invested in in terms
of coherent, in terms of momentum, those
companies are leading. Now we saw a
correction in that space. So like under
the story of memory being corrected, we
saw the photonic space be corrected
>> and now
quietly is kept. We've watched them
rebound. Now nobody's talking about it,
but if you look at what Lmentum's done,
the ticker is LI T. Lit is the ticker.
It's rebounded here, right? We're going
to retest a thousand very shortly.
Coherent, I just told you about how
reported and how time, you know, if you
were trying to get these dailies or you
trying to get the weeklies, it didn't
work in your favor. Coherent closed at
351. It's going to test it all time
highs. And so, some of people looking
like, "Hey, I missed the boat. These
stocks are pretty high."
>> Well, they just created a Photonix ETF,
right? Write this ticker down. LY ly.
Why is that important? for the same
reason when I was telling you about DRAM
when you said Sanders has run we can't
afford it from an individual standpoint
and Micron has run we can't uh invest in
it from an individual standpoint this
now gives you an allocation to a space
that is going to lead it is necessary
inside of the AI infrastructure
specifically the data data center space
to how information will be transferred
number one more efficient number one
faster number two faster
>> yeah way faster
if you're looking to have exposure to
the photonic space because yeah to
invest there's so many companies Troy
and I number one I look at hey what is
Nvidia invested in what's in the fund
who are they spending with right if you
look at that that's that that sometimes
they have that that's that pie chart of
the companies they're investing look at
them synopsis cadence we've spoke about
that in detail coherent momentum even
SpaceX now there's a reason why now you
could say circular economy but they are
protecting their interest and they're
becoming the central bank. So they're
loaning out the money and they're
loaning out the product and they're
getting return on investment.
This is a sector sub sector really that
we need to make sure that that we're
involved in. If and if you feel like hey
>> you know I got so many individual
equities I don't know if I want to pay
$900 for light. I understand the story
but the other opportunities this will be
an opportunity just like when we talked
about GEV in terms of energy and we
talked about Caterpillar. This will be a
sector and this is an ETF that you
should have on your watch list and
potentially potentially maybe make a
colon. LY
don't say you heard it anywhere else.
You heard it here. It just opened last
week.
>> All right. But make sure you put on your
watch list.
>> We're both thinking the same thing. Just
expressed it in different ways at
Investfest. I talked about EV.
>> Yeah. Yeah. So I I like it. If we get
back down to $21.39,
I like that for entry. Um, but I
definitely agree. Some of the companies
are so phenomenal. They are pricey
though. So, if you want a cheaper way to
do so, I think, um, for those of you who
are asking, hey, I need two more or one
more to invest in, um, you can't go
wrong with LT or my selection in EUV.
So, Ray Miles think alike.
>> EUV is
>> damn the 500 people missed out on.
>> They ain't here. They ain't here. It's
all right. It's all right. They be like,
yo, yo, they gonna wait till they see it
on Instagram.
>> Yeah, [laughter] gotcha.
>> It's going to be the voice over. You
know what the next ETF is?
>> No, they going to be the people on
Instagram like, "Yo, y'all never
>> y don't give any value.
>> Y'all only wait till things go up before
you."
>> That was the older you. The newer you is
really focusing on the people that are
here taking advantage of this moment.
>> No, 100%. [laughter] Uh, seven financial
moves before 40. I'm going say seven
because I've seen this uh question
online and I'll let everybody chime in
if you're interested, but real quick.
Um, all right. If you're not 40 yet, for
the young world out there, you're in
your 20s, you're in your 30s, definitely
got to have three to six months of an
emergency fund because that's important.
I always tell people, even before you
start investing, you got to learn to
save money. Uh, anything could happen.
The average person, I think, is like
probably a couple paychecks away from
really being in a financial disaster,
damn near homeless. So, man, the job
market is is crazy right now. Nothing is
certain. So learn to save, be
disciplined. You create a budget, learn
to save, put money away. 3 to 6 months
for s for expenses. Try to eliminate
highinterest debt.
>> Credit card. Credit cards especially.
Try to eliminate that. We we've got
shows on how to eliminate debt, snowball
method, all types of different stuff.
But try to eliminate high interest debt.
Stay away from high interest debt. All
debt is not bad debt, but high interest
credit card debt is bad debt.
>> [clears throat]
>> Um, maximize your retirement accounts.
Um, if you have a 401k at your job,
contribute to the match. Uh, Roth IRA,
IRA. We got a bunch of videos about
that. If you're a business owner,
there's a SE IRA, Simple IRA. Put money
away for your retirement. It has,
especially if you're not if you're not
doing the the Roth, you're going to get
a tax benefit from it. If you are doing
the Roth, you won't get a tax benefit,
but it's going to be taxfree money down
the line, which none of your other money
will be taxree. That's the only money
that you won't have to pay taxes on. Um
build your first um $100,000
portfolio. That should be your goal to
get to 100,000. The first before you
first goal is to get to 10,000. Get to
10,000 then you get to 100,000.
>> Yep.
>> Then you start to play. Once you get to
100,000, now you get you got momentum at
your back. But
>> the first thing you got to do is get
that 100,000.
>> Whatever you got to do,
>> you got to stay home for for two years.
If you just get to the hundred thousand,
that's gonna put
>> wind behind your back and and then you
gonna start to really
>> get get in your in in your in your in
your groove. Um
>> that's the number, too. I'm glad you
said that.
>> 100,000. So, man, SMH, I made a lot of
money on SMH. Uh QQQ, I've been talking
about QQQ for so long. You know, you got
the S&P 500, you got uh VTI. Put
together your portfolio.
Put together your portfolio. Stick with
your portfolio. Be focused on your
portfolio. Focus on what you invest in.
Get to that 100,000. That's vitally
important. Dollar cost average every
single month. Dollar cost average. Just
I can't say this enough. Dollar cost
average. Figure out how much money you
can put away and put that away every
single month. When you get your tax
refund, put that money into the market.
Get a h 100,000. Get your 100,000. Um,
get life insurance
>> for sure.
>> My laws especially. Yeah, vital.
>> Okay, this is vitally important because
you're healthy nine times out of 10.
>> Your health is not always going to be
there.
>> Anything can happen. When you're young,
the premiums are lower and you're
healthy so you can you can get it. Even
if you don't have a family, get insured.
Get life insurance. Get disability
insurance. Get insured. That is very
very very important. Create a will and
estate plan. Once again, you can always
change it. you can update it. The
earlier you do it, the better. Um, and
the last thing I'll say is create a
budget for sure.
>> I'll say too, create a budget. Budgeting
is the most underrated thing when it
comes to
>> even if you're rich. Not to cut you,
even if you're rich, live within a
budget.
>> Create a budget and have and and also
create your financial freedom number.
That way that you you have something to
work towards. We need as human beings,
we need goals to work towards.
>> If you have a number, put it on your
ceiling, put it on your phone, have it
as your screen saver, and just every
single day look at that number because
psychologically that's going to force
you to work harder, make sacrifices, be
more disciplined.
>> Yeah, I love
>> Yeah. I just I Somebody asked a
question. I thought it was a really good
question. They said what's the
difference between EUV the ETF and LY?
Um both are lightbased manufacturing. I
think you would think of it in terms of
what's the difference between SMH and
DRAM
>> right where like SMH has a lot of the
semis. It has Nvidia. It has TSM. It has
Broadcom. It has Micron. It has Texas
Instrument. It has AMD. So it's a broad
range where DRAM is very specific to
memory where it has SKH highix it has
Samsung it has Micron Sandis uh Seagate
and Western Digital all inside of that.
So when you think of EUV light base from
the manufacturing standpoint all the way
down. So TSM leads that in terms of
allocation. Uh you got ASML, Applied
Materials, Lamb's in there, Kam,
uh KLA, Corning's in there, and then
Lamentum, you'll see them at the bottom
like Sienna's in there, Coherent. Inside
of light, the top three, Lum, Coherent,
Sienna, right? So it's very hyperfocused
specifically on on photonics inside of
the EUV, lithography machine, uh light
manufacturing companies. So just just a
couple differences.
>> Yeah, it's a great breakdown.
>> Yeah.
>> Light lightning round. This is
>> this segment. Let's go.
>> Oh boy.
>> This is triggering.
>> All right. So we're gonna do this,
right? So we got a lightning round.
We're going to say two companies and we
have to choose either or. Now, are you
giving us a segue here where we can say
both or is it it just strictly has to be
either or because this is triggering.
>> I made it to be triggering because we
were triggered all week. So
>> 7 7777 on the checkin
>> golly
>> magical number. So So let's do even next
week we can say which ones are both but
for this week let's do
>> just like quick time with slime. All
right bet. [laughter]
>> All right. So first up let's let's go
right after it. Nvidia or Broadcom.
>> It's a closer matchup than people would
think given my love for Nvidia. Um but
I'm definitely going with Nvidia.
Uh I am with I am with you on Nvidia.
Love Broadcom. Um they got beat up last
week. Uh but the story is still very
evident when it comes to silicone, when
it comes to who's going to be making
custom ASIC. They're going to lead. If
we see more people going to into the
space saying, "Hey, we can't afford your
GPU," which I'm assuming most people
can't. Can we build our own? Can we
white label it? Broadcom will be in that
space. They did lose a key client. They
did lose a key client. the Google
relationship is teetering a little bit.
Um, Nvidia is just too strong. I I would
say this, you put Nvidia in any other
company and I'm taking Nvidia. So,
that's why I'm standing.
>> Yeah.
>> Shotty.
>> Nvidia.
>> All right. Number two. This is a good
one.
>> Tesla or Palunteer?
[sighs and snorts]
I don't want you to invest in the
company for moral [laughter] reasons.
I'm anti-war even though I'm pro
Anderero for personal reasons. Um
because I like Lucky Story against, you
know, get coming back from the dead from
Meta, etc. But if I had to pick, I
really think Palanteer has more upside.
My stance is not I know some of y'all on
threads tried to do it. Yo, he ain't
told you to invest in Palunteer. No, I
didn't. I've been one of the few people
that's I actually turned down um getting
it before it went public.
>> You gota look at Meta because Meta's
been pushing. I didn't threads just been
going viral. I learned this from my
>> my recent
>> thread. These things happen on threads
before they even hit Instagram. So
>> they're like an incubator and then they
go over from threads to
mainstage. Yeah. Yeah. It's great great
research craft. So
yeah, but once again,
>> I don't want you to invest in it. But if
I'm just talking company for company
with better potential return, also
because I think Elon is more focused on
SpaceX, i.e. Starlink, I don't think his
love is there anymore as much for Tesla.
Um, so for this one, I'm going to have
to pick Palanteer.
>> I'm going to agree with you again. And I
think Palanteer, the upside here is is
is
pretty pretty substantial. Um, in terms
of what they're now doing outside of
just government contracting, which was
kind of the focus. I know they had the
high valuation. They kind of got beat up
for that. Um, they've had a nice run
after earnings here because of where the
money is now coming from. It's not
solely, hey, government contract.
They're getting into the B2B uh
businesses. And so now that is a
different model for them. I like that.
Tesla. I just feel like Tesla's kind of
just floating along and I just feel like
there's they're just gonna get merged at
some point in the near future. Yeah.
>> And so if this was a SpaceX versus
Palanteer, I would probably go with
SpaceX.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. But I I just feel like Tesla is
going to is going to be part of that
that umbrella in SpaceX. And then we
like you said, you've been saying this
for a few weeks now. Where is the proof
of the thing, right? Because robotics
was supposed to have this the autonomous
vehicles. They had that whole roll out.
Kim K was in the car. It was the whole
thing.
>> I haven't seen one hit the street yet.
>> Yet.
>> And then I just saw that the Cyber Truck
was rated the worst truck in the history
of automotives,
>> which is not a great sign. Um, so I
don't know how the Model S is doing in
sales. I know China is
>> kicking their backs in when it comes to
the autonomous with with the the uh
electric vehicles from all the brands
that they have. Obviously, we've
traveled internationally and we we've
seen it firsthand of what that looks
like.
>> Yeah. So, yeah, the Model S did I was I
thought it got cancelled, but I
appreciate that. Yeah, the Model S got I
I'm just not sure with Tesla anymore.
Obviously, we don't think of it as an
automotive company, but from the techn
technological standpoint, I think the
focus is SpaceX and this will just be
part of it. Who you going with?
>> Tesla Palanteer.
>> Um, you know, my moral compass won't
allow me to.
>> Smart move, my brother.
Either either one.
>> All right, let's get interesting here,
Ian. Let's get interested. Microsoft or
or Alphabet.
[sighs]
>> I want you to start by saying I want you
to start off by saying that's my baby.
that that's this is really tough. This
this is one of the ones where I would
say both.
But
if I have to pick even though Google has
is losing some talent and they're
getting some of their talent poached,
I may I I may lean towards Google. No,
it doesn't change my two tech
uh
philosophy,
but if I had to pick
right now, which one is better because
of the flub with open AI, the Sam, I
even remember that Sunday when they had
that Kuruffle a few years ago, they
brought him back in
um currently at 48035. Worst case
scenario, we could drop back to 404.
Both amazing companies, but if I had to
just do it like on a Kangelo draft
basis,
>> yeah,
>> I'm gonna pick Google. I'm not gonna
lie.
>> Yo, we are three for three on this, bro.
Uh I'm taking Google as well. I I think
I mean we both agreed it was interesting
at the at the end of last year that
Google will be our pick for the stock
>> of the year this year for most of the
reason obviously from the different
verticals that they have for revenue
generating but where they're going to in
the future in terms of artificial
intelligence what they've done what
their investment in SpaceX the fact that
we just saw Birkshshire Hathway make it
his third largest position in the fund
is is very telling right when they don't
even like to new technology, right? It
was just Apple.
>> They don't even like tech, but the fact
that they've added
>> Google
>> and so much capital to it.
>> Exact. And they they see something. They
see it too. They see the different
verticals that they have. Obviously,
YouTube, uh, Gemini, I mean, all the
things that you can think of that are
going in this direction. Plus, they have
probably the most talented group of
engineers when you think of DeepMind.
>> Absolutely. um love Microsoft, but I I
got to go Google.
>> And they've had less missteps. For all
my Microsoft HQ people, I love y'all.
That has not changed. Please don't email
me. It's been a rough week. Um but but I
will say [laughter]
draw down Microsoft's open our
relationship. If you dig into that
circular investment story,
it could be concerning. The one company
in a hyperscaler where you have really
no concerns is Google. Like regard like
YouTube could be publicly traded on its
own
>> by itself. Yep. Yep.
>> By itself. So they have very little
mistakes and sometimes in a game of life
who makes the least amount of mistakes
matters a lot more. I was telling my son
this this past week. I'm like you're
talented but if a kid turns the ball
over less than you, he can be better
than you just by not turning the ball
over. And and I think the thing that
Google has outclassed Apple and
Microsoft in is not making any mistakes
really in this race.
>> Yeah, we we used I mean we were on here
maybe a few years ago saying it was a
branding issue. Um but they were just
building as we were saying that and we
spoke to some of the people over there
um from the the TPU which I I thought
was a great innovation uh from them from
a technological standpoint of saying hey
we're going to build within. I know what
everybody else is doing. We're going to
build within the advertising business.
Obviously, we can see where everything
is is headed. When you're looking at the
future of our the next generation, where
will they be living? They'll be living
on YouTube and they'll probably be
streaming somewhere that runs adjacent
to it.
>> There's just so much going for it. I
think the Open AI relationship with
Microsoft is an interesting one. Um, but
they still are relying on other
companies, right, for their for their
compute, definitely for their power. I
know the Constellation Energy uh
partnership is important, but they still
are reliant and I mean it it they're
still enterprise, right? So like what
does enterprise software look like in 10
years? I don't know.
>> Will they be at the forefront of it? I'm
pretty sure. But it it could look very
different.
>> They have to reimagine in the same way
the meta needs to reimagine parts of the
business. For sure.
>> I think I like that word. Let's
reimagine.
>> Let's reimagine.
>> Uh I'm gonna go with Microsoft.
>> Oh.
>> Okay. Okay.
>> It's further down from its all-time
high. So, as far as the growth
potential, even though it recovered a
lot.
>> Yeah.
>> Um but, you know, you look at I don't
know, it's just Microsoft's um AI
infrastructure,
their investments in companies, they
always got a trick up their sleeve.
They've been down for a number of years.
You got to think that, you know, at some
point in time, they're going to have a
rally for multi-year rally for sure. Um
>> and they're leader in the space. They're
best in class. Mhm.
I just think that Microsoft is just in
in a class by themselves in in a lot of
different categories. And they've been
here they they they've lasted.
>> Yeah, they weathered a bunch of storms
for sure.
>> They they weathered the storm. They have
they have strong leadership.
So yeah, I mean I think Microsoft is is
a company that's going to be here for a
long time.
>> Okay. And I'm I'mma throw a remix here.
So we have Apple, AMD, but I don't even
think that's a fair battle, right? Like
>> I want to be fair.
>> I think I think this How about this
though? What if we said Apple, Amazon?
>> Oh, for sure. Apple. There's no
question.
>> Apple.
>> No question. I I'm going to start to
Well, I've said it, but I took um Amazon
out of our top four in stock club
>> a couple months ago. Do I think they
have
>> I just same thing. Draw down,
>> elimination of risk. The one thing that
Apple did do incredibly well is they did
not overspend. Now, that was not their
sole decision to do so. Sometimes in
being inactive, it can benefit you. I
don't like that they're not aggressive
enough, but what has benefited them is
that you don't hear some of these
hyperscaler horror stories as a result.
Now, I'm looking forward to see now it's
going to be a battle of the new CEO
>> versus Jesse. That's going to be
interesting. Interesting lineup. But
just in terms of a return basis, they've
been able to almost act as like uh a
bank of sorts because they're still
getting a 30% out of the app store. They
didn't overspend. That's helped the
return on capital is strong. So, if I
had to pick one, it would be Apple for
sure.
>> This is where I'm going to differ from
you here. I'm going Amazon.
>> Okay.
>> Um I think everything you said is true.
Again, these are both great companies
and definitely
>> companies you should have in your
long-term portfolio. Um, Amazon is
tricky. I don't do options on it. Um,
because it's just it's never worked in
my
>> Yeah, it never works in my favor and I
had to learn that for myself. So, I'm
happy about that. But I do have it in a
long portfolio
>> partly because of the same reason I
looked at Google and said look at all
the verticals that they are
participating in
>> and Amazon probably out of all those
hyperscalers has the most verticals. Now
you did mention the capex spend. They
are the largest capex spender by a a
large margin, but I think they have some
very talented leaders in terms of
engineering. Obviously, Jasse as a CEO
has done a really good job
>> that they're investing this with the
expectation of a return and I think that
return is going to come to fruition. The
Apple piece is interesting because we
used to talk about it in terms of where
is the revenue coming from and we we
talked about obviously you know Apple
Music
uh we talked about the iPod all all the
discretionary things but large the
largest uh portion of of the revenue
comes from still the iPhone in fact it's
actually increased.
>> iPhone [clears throat] used to be 50% of
revenue. Last quarter it reported that
it's 68% of revenue. Yeah, incredible
moat.
>> It is. They probably to do something
with AI with those phones.
>> Yes. So, they they have they are the the
highway into AI in a sense where if
you're going to use an app, you'll
probably use it on their phone.
>> I just think there's going to be a new
technology that's going to appear soon.
And I don't think we're going to be
holding it.
>> I just don't think we're going to be
it's not going to be something that's
handheld anymore, right? So, like, yes,
we have this this phone and the 18 will
come out and we probably have that, but
I just think in five to seven year,
maybe seven to 10 years, it won't be
something that's handheld anymore. And I
don't know if Apple's going to be the
person that creates the thing. And so,
for if I'm thinking of long-term, I
think it's a strong company. I just
don't know if the way we use these
things here is going to be the same in
in 10 years.
>> Instagram got your what Kanye say?
[laughter]
Instagram got your B. Listen,
[__] won't put down the I put
up a post. Y'all can't get rich because
you can't get off your phone for six
hours. Then I had a whole bunch of
people. I make money off my phone. Most
of the people who make a bunch of money
not on their phone all day. I say that
to say the addiction problem in the
Black Mirror, I don't think that's going
to be on the decline.
>> So, um, in a margin. Yeah. Yeah. Um,
Apple's up 32% for the year. Amazon's up
12.8.
Um, I do think they once again they need
to reimagine the product and how that
looks uh as well, but I don't see them
giving up that lead anytime soon. And
definitely not the open AI. I know y'all
went and got Johnny and y'all got your
partnership and yada yada, but that pen
and all that other [__] not as
promising.
>> I thought you was going to talk about
the the margins because the margins is
very different.
>> Oh, the margins. Yeah,
>> Apple's margins are very different than
Amazon's margin, but they do spend more.
Um, you want to do you want to do one
more then we can get some questions from
the audience before we before we head
out?
>> I got I got I got two because we got to
do it just because I I feel like Ian
tried to trigger me. So I want to hear
his response. Eli Lily or G Evenova?
>> That's like picking between a Ferrari
and a Lamborghini. Yo, like
you can't go wrong with either.
I think with the peptide movement, I
think Lily is going to have
>> an even more robust future. But if I'm
going to be very honest and just look at
it and take my love of the company away,
I'mma probably go Jeie Venova.
>> Damn.
>> Indianapolis, I love y'all. Lily gang
forever, all that.
>> But if I'm looking at just high returns,
>> I'm with you.
>> Damn, I just thought you I knew you was
going Lily, but
>> Okay, that makes sense. I'm with you. I
think Genova healthcare will definitely
be disruptive especially when it's
health tech. Uh Genova will be vitally
important because we can't we don't have
enough energy now um to power what we're
trying to to bring to the grid. They
play a vital role in
>> my phone going off already [laughter]
>> and making adaptations to how we get
power and they're doing it from an
international standpoint. I'm I'm taking
Genova. Last one. Sand See, who you got?
>> [sighs]
>> God, it's tough. Um,
both are amazing companies.
You can't go wrong with either. Um,
I don't [sighs and gasps]
I'm going say Sandisk. I mean, it's it's
it's
Kobe, Braun, Jordan, Braun. You gonna
win either way. Um, I think Sandisk
Price and Power is amazing. I think they
have a great mode if uh I'm really
splitting hairs here because either one
would be great, but I'mma lean on
Sandis.
>> I'm going with Sandis as well. We made
too much history together. I can't turn
my back. I'm just loyal. Um Seagate is
is a phenomenal company. They've
actually probably done, if we're talking
about the memory space, they're number
two, right? We always talk about Micron,
but Seagate has actually had a better
year um from that solid state nand uh
memory story. uh they control pricing
and I think the partnerships that we've
seen Sandis be able to curate they named
11 that that that pricing power is still
going to to to be there for the next
three to four years plus the brand
recognition. I don't know how many
people like oh I have that se people
know Sandis even if they don't know
Sandis because they walk into CVS and
it's at the counter or they took a
picture in their camera and that's the
memory card they've been using their
entire life and now it's a company that
they invest in. So I'm going with them
as well.
All right. All right. Well, let's get
some questions if we can put some
questions in chat. And while y'all
putting the questions in chat, do
remember there's 10 slots that's been
open for the Red Panda three-year deal.
Threeear access to Red Panda for the
price of one. Get you get the stocks at
the price to buy it. You get one year
access to Sniper, which is the future
trading setup. You get the 10 stocks to
invest in now. the monthly calls,
community, the whole the whole red panda
rebellion, Red Panda millionaires, Red
Panda army
>> for sure,
>> the whole gang. So, it was 25 slots. Due
to popular demand, we opened up 10 more
slots. So, first come, first serve. Go
to ianinvest.com.
Let's answer some questions from the
audience if we can before we head out.
>> I saw I saw just a good one. Somebody
just asked, "Outside of Lily, what would
be another solid healthcare company that
we would look at?" I think that's a good
one.
>> That's a great question. Um,
Stock Club, I won't give ours away
outside of Lily for the public. There
isn't one
that I'm personally invested in.
So, uh, like I know HIMS is is cheap and
affordable. That's a pharma adjacent,
but the pricing structure isn't well, I
wouldn't buy that unless it got back
down to nine bucks or 10 bucks. So, no
there. Novo, no Johnson and Johnson.
Even though the
the equity has gone up, just the history
with uh cancer causing agents in
products, that's a no. Madna and also
Lily is the only one I can currently
recommend.
>> Okay, somebody asked this is a good one
as well. I thought that Oh, wait. Mike
just put up one. It says, "If I have 6K
to deploy in the market, how should I
divide that up between two tech index?"
>> The same way you do the sandwich at
lunchtime in fours like a little
>> That's easy.
>> Yeah, man. Divide the capital. Put them
in.
>> Yeah. Put them in.
>> Oh, somebody said striker. Yep. Carlos.
Carlos, you're back. Me amigo. Thank you
my boy. Striker.
>> That's crazy. Yo, I had Striker on my
phone. Shotty as my witness. I was like,
"Yo, is he not going to say striker?"
>> I was thinking Pharma, but I'm tired.
Yeah. Yeah.
>> So, somebody asked and they said, "Troy,
what's the difference between uh photo
and light?" Um, this is important. I I
should
>> Let me real quick. I mean to be real.
Hold on.
>> Yeah. Go. So, when we look at ETFs now,
a bunch of them have been created. We
can see that. Mike, go full screen for
us real quick.
>> Bathroom break. That's a first
>> bladder control.
>> All right. So, it's important to see who
is originating the ETF. And so, there
are some really strong ones. Obviously,
when we talk about SMH, we're talking
about Van, and that's a strong,
reputable, been here for years. When
we're talking about XLK, we're talking
about State Street and Spider. We know
that. Invesco from QQQ. Those are
strong, legitimate, been here financial
institutions. We know that. When you're
looking at who's been hot this year,
I would argue Round Hill is probably the
number one outside of the the, you know,
the staples that I just mentioned. Round
Hills, who uh originated the the DRAM
ETF, which was probably one of the most,
you know, dynamic ETFs in the history of
the market. It was what the fastest to
raise a billion just ridiculous numbers.
So now Round is who was actually put out
uh light l Y T not L I T that would be
the individual company photo is by
Tuttle which is again reputable not as
known not as popular. So here's what
happens in the space they might have
been the first to come to the market
with an ETF that is specifically for
Photonix. The problem is when an
established company like Roundhill comes
in, you know what happens to the volume
of of this one? They leave because they
watch what they did with DRAM already
and they're like, "Oh, that's where the
volume should go." And so pay attention
to that. Who's originated? Direction is
another one that's solid. Look at who's
originating the ETFs. Look at the volume
that goes with that and that should help
you make a decision. Also inside of the
allocations if you look I think lentum
is like 14% and coherent is like 13% and
it's a a little bit less in photo. I
just looked at it was like 6% and 4%. So
take that into account as well.
>> All right. Oh man, what a day. What a
journey. [laughter] What a life.
>> Yo, you see the shirt, right? Shout out
to Shout out to Lauren Hill, man. It
could all be so simple. It could all be
so simple.
>> Shout out to EO Africa. Follow EL Africa
page.
>> We got some We got some content. We
putting up content. We got more content
coming on the continent.
>> Oh man.
What do you think about the new Invesco
in ETFs?
>> The new ones. I mean, that's a broad
question. Which one?
>> Specific one.
>> Yeah. What specific one are you talking
about? Like I said, there's there's a
thousand a thousand ETFs that are going
to be generated this year.
>> Ian's back. I might go back. He's back.
There's a thousand being generated this
year to say which one. I mean, pick a
sector. Which one you talking about?
>> Um, okay. Well,
>> man, and I'll say this, too. With so
many ETFs being listed
outside of Invesco and Black Rockck,
Vanguard, all of them are not for your
benefit.
Get having too many choices is going to
lead to financial decay and decay in
your personal life.
rock with with the ones that have been
working. Like trust me, like
>> I can't tell too much inside ball, but
this is going to continue to grow. And
the scary part is they want the ETF
market to catch up with the number of
publicly traded stocks that are
available as that's because there's
[clears throat] not enough great
companies to go public. Be very careful
>> here. Here's the other part. Uh the
volume thing is something you should
watch, right? Like if you if if Vanguard
puts out one, if Brown Hill puts, if if
uh Invesco puts out one, the other part
is that if it some of these other ones
don't get volume, you know what happens
to that ETF?
>> They closing.
>> Fenito,
>> it's over. It's not like, oh, it's got
to list. No, it's closed and shut down.
>> So, just you just got to be mindful of
those things.
>> It's a fact, man. It's been a hell of a
show.
>> Rashad, you did an amazing job, my
brother.
>> I appreciate it, man.
>> Shout out to everybody that tapped in.
Wednesday, we got a it's gonna be a
crazy blackout. We got 19 keys and Van
Lean on Wednesday and we got Serena
Williams on Thursday at 12 o'clock.
Serena Williams on Thursday at 12:00.
So, this week is a crazy week. Go to
Ianvest.com if you want to join Stock
Club for three years. 10 slots, first
come first serve. Uh alltime high for
this year time uh 2026 high for this
year today. We we we broke that 8,500
people on the viewership. Amazing. Thank
you to the 500 who left too. I love you.
Thank you for your viewership and
support. Love you guys.
>> Oh man.
>> Invest present. My presentation um well
my slides will be in stock club this
Saturday. Um call this Friday. Look in
Telegram and thank you for the support
or hate either way it comes. I
appreciate you all.
>> Yeah, for sure. And yeah, if you want to
watch my public address, you could
rewatch this. It was like 30 minutes
into the episode. Um,
>> so
>> you clip it.
>> You gonna clip your own content.
>> I know the Clippers ain't going to clip
it. Um, they're not going to clip that,
but I don't know. I feel like, like I
said, I wanted to just talk to Market
Mondays. I'm not even really concerned
about social media. Half the people on
social media, they never really took the
time to watch Market Mondays anyway. So,
if I lost you, I never had you. But I
really appreciate Market Mondays. so
much. I appreciate everybody that
watches. Thank you so much. Um, if you
guys want us to do Investf Fest next
year, let us know. We can do it. If not,
then it's wrap it up.
>> It's been a hell of a run, man. Like,
you know,
>> sometimes if people don't fully
appreciate it, stop Red Panda tell like
one person, yo, you canled the call. I'm
like, yo, I'm with my kid. He he needed
me real quick, but let's go to once a
month. Sometimes people don't fully
appreciate what you bring to the table
unless you take it away. Yeah.
>> Yeah. But shout out to y'all. Shout out
to
>> gota leave on top sometimes like
Mayweather.
>> Shout out to this community. Um number
one obviously tapping in but growing
with us.
>> It ain't sassy. It's real. Yo.
>> Yeah. No. No. I'm saying they they they
growing with us but number one they
coming back because they've executed on
information. If they didn't execute on
information they wouldn't come back.
>> Sassy. No [__] We next week we
45 minute show. But but no,
>> I said this earlier, right? Either they
can win with us
>> or they can watch us win. So, it's a
choice. Everybody got a decision to
make. Win with us or watch us win.
>> That's it.
>> And shout out to Indiana. Shout out to
Shout out to Gary, Indiana, East
Chicago.
>> Yeah.
>> Nap
Cooko, Terra Ho,
>> God,
>> South Bend. And and and for the select
few who may not like me, I won.
[laughter]
I won. Me, Kenny Loftton, Etoan.
>> Can we get Kenny Loftton in the Hall of
Fame, please?
>> ASAP. He should have been in there.
>> Come on.
>> And um man, if worse come to worse, if
you don't like me, there's always Troy
in. Um that's a good thing about
partnership, you know.
>> [__] I'm I've been doing, you know,
like when women check out the
relationship early. [laughter]
>> Oh man,
>> let the hate get loud. Wrap it up.
>> I tell you before we before we leave,
man, it's been a hell of a ride, man.
And who would have thought honestly like
I I said this a few people 10 years ago
if I would have told you the number one
trending topics for four weeks straight
would be a a business investing
conference and a platform that talks
about stocks, credit, real estate
>> and and finances.
>> And that would be the number one
trending topic for four weeks in black
culture. And it would be bigger than
sports and it would be bigger than
entertainment. You would look at me like
I was crazy for real.
>> So sometimes you just got to count your
blessings. It's a blessing to even be in
this position.
>> I mean, it's what we asked for. Um, and
and it's come true. And it's it's it's
really kind of amazing if you really
think about it. The subject that's been
the hardest to actually permeate and the
hardest to actually make people
gravitate towards has become
>> so entertaining and so so much part of
popular culture that it goes viral every
other day. And we're on your timeline
every other day. Good, bad, or
indifferent.
>> Mhm.
>> 30,000 people come to Investfest. 8,500
people on this live. Man, who would have
thought? Who would have thought?
>> Black people would love it.
>> I'm rooting for everyone black.
>> Even if you support you.
>> Yeah.
>> Indiana. Love Elcart, Indiana.
South Ben.
>> Shout out to Jackson, Mississippi, man.
Shout out to Zebo
[laughter]
Mike. Fade the black on us, man.